EVERYDAY USERS IS ONLY THE
BEGINNING OF HOW IT WILL CHANGE
THE ECONOMIES OF CALIFORNIA THE
UNITED STATES AND THE ENTIRE
WORLD IN FACT NUMEROUS STUDIES
AND EARLY APPLICATIONS OF FIVE
G. AT ITS HIGHEST BAND WITH
HAVE INDICATED THAT IT IS NOT
MERELY USEFUL FOR STREAMING
MOVIES. SHOWS OR PLAYING GAMES
EIGHT PROMISES ALSO TO
FUNDAMENTALLY REVOLUTIONIZED
THE POTENTIALS OF EVERY
INDUSTRY AND GOVERNMENT ENTITY.
FOR EXAMPLE WHEN THE POTNTIAL
OF HIGH BAND FIVE G. IS
UNLOCKED AT A HOSPITAL ITS
ABILITY TO TREAT PATIENTS IS
GREATLY ELEVATED EIGHT ASSURING
IS ABLE TO HAPPEN
INSTANTANEOUSLY BETWEEN
AMBULANCE VEHICLES AND E. R.
ROOMS TIONS CAN BE MONITOR FROM
THEIR HOMES TELEHEALTH
APPOINTMENTS BECOME PRACTICAL
FOR MORE PATIENT NEEDS AND
FIELDS OF PRACTICE THESE ARE
EXAMPLES OF HOW FIVE G. CAN
IMPROVE HEALTH CARE YOU MAY
ALSO CHANGE OTHER CRITICAL
FEELS LIKE MANUFACTURING RETAIL
TRANSPORTATION CONSTRUCTION
UTILITIES EDUCATION AND OTHERS.
SO HOW WOULD THESE INDUSTRIES
AND OUR ECONOMY BE AFFECTED
THOUGHT BY FIVE G. FINALLY
IMPLEMENTING AND BUILDING OUT
FIVE G. NETWORKS ALSO INVOLVES
AND RELIES ON WORKING WITH
STAKEHOLDERS AT THE STATE AND
LOCAL LEVELS OF GOVERNMENT.
INCLUDING THE COMMUNITIES THAT
HAVE A VESTED INTEREST IN ITS
ROLLOUT TO THAT END WE AS
LEGISLATORS WANT TO DEVELOP AN
UNDERSTANDING OF FIVE G. ITS
CAPABILITIES AND ALSO WORK WITH
THESE MULTIPLE STAKEHOLDERS
WHEN IT COMES TO DEPLOYING AND
IMPLEMENTING FIVE G. I'M
CONFIDENT THAT OUR PANELISTS
WILL PROVIDE ALL OF THOSE. WITH
THE INFORMATION NECESSARY TO
UNDERSTAND FIVE G. AND ANSWER
SOME OF THE QUESTIONS THAT I
RAISED EARLIER. WITHTHAT
INFORMATION MY HOPE IS THAT WE
CAN WORK TOGETHER TOWARD
DEVELOPING SOLUTIONS FOR FIVE
G. RELATED ISSUES THAT THE
LEGISLATURE SEEKS TO ADDRESS
AGAIN I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
BEING HERE TODAY I LOOK FORWARD
TO A ROBUST AND INFORMATIVE
DISCUSSION SO WITH THAT- LET ME
INTRODUCE OUR FIRST PANEL. THE
FIRST PANEL WILL HELP DISCUSS
THE SUB TOPIC FEATURES OF FIVE
G. AND ITS IMPACT ON THE
ECONOMY AND DATA WE HAVE DOCTOR
TIGER AW MAN UP GOAL PAUL
ACTING DEPUTY DIVISION DIRECTOR
AT THE NATIONAL SCIENCE
FOUNDATION. AND DR KIRTI GUPTA
VICE PRESIDENT OF ECONOMIC
STRATEGY AND CHIEF ECONOMIST AT
QUALCOMM INC. SO WELCOME AND
PLEASE FEEL FREE TO BEGIN.
SOMETHING AND SHALL BE THE
APPRECIATE GIVING US AN
OPPORTUNITY TO- NATIONAL
SCIENCE FOUNDATION AND COME AND
BRIEF- THIS AUGUST BODY ON THE
IMPORTANCE OF FIVE G. I. DID
TAKE THE LEAD ON THE PRODUCT OF
FOLLOW ME ON THE ON THE
FEATURES OF FIVE G. AND HIS
IMPACT ON THE ECONOMY AND THE
DATA I OF YOU ALL AGREE THAT
WIRELESS ACROSS THE JUST THINK
IT'S BECOME AT THE SAME COM OF
SOCIETY AND IT AND- THE LAST
DECADE HAS SHOWN THAT. ENTIRELY
NEW SERVICES THE PUBLIC AND
PRIVATE SECTORS OF COME ABOUT.
BECAUSE OF THE SLACKNESS
COMMUNICATION NETWORKS BUT SO
MUCH STARTED OFF AS- A SIMPLE
CALIFORNIA SERVICE. GREW UP
INTO. THREE G. WHICH BROUGHT US
TEXT MESSAGING BLACKBODY THE
NINETIES. AND LATE NINETIES AND
THEN. THE LAST OF THE LAST TEN
YEARS YOU HAVE REALLY MOVED ON-
AND SEEN A TRANSFORMATION BY
THE ADVENT OF. SMART PHONES
WHICH ARE USED THAT. ARE
PRESENT HIGH SPEED
COMMUNICATION NETWORKS A DEEP
CUTS AFFECT US FOR G.
UNLEASHING A RANGE OF SERVICES
JOBS. AND MULTIBILLION DOLLAR
COMPANIES THAT ARE ON HURDLE
THAT DIDN'T EXIST JUST ADVOCATE
RIGHT SO THIS IS THE FAULT OF
CONSUMMATION. THAT WIRELESS
CONNECTIVITY AS DELIVERED AND
IT'S NOT JUST WITHIN THE US
GLOBAL GLOBAL CONSUMMATION OF
INDUSTRIES. AND THE WHOLE
PEOPLE PERCEIVE AND COMMUNICATE
OVERALL. SO BE MORE DISTINCTLY
NEARLY. NOW THE PAST YEAR DEL
ENDEMICI SHOWN THOSE- CRITICAL
ACCESS TO INTERNET IT'S- AN
ESPECIALLY WIRELESS BOXES
BECAUSE- THAT IS A- VERY VERY
VERY MUCH 99% OF PEOPLE I'LL
LEARN TO USE THE INTERNET. EVEN
A SMALL TO WIFI RIGHT. THE NEW
OWN MARKETS DOING ALL WHAT A
WIRED CONNECTION NEEDS FOR ALL
THE DAY PROBABLY. HAD NEVER
SEEN I PRETTY MUCH ALL SECTORS
OF SOCIETY RIGHT RELATED GOOD
INTO MY AND DATA TO UNDERSTAND
AND MANAGE THEIR LIFE DURING
THE OF AND IT IS CRITICAL THAT
THE DEMAND FOR FOSSIL COMMITTEE
THIS NOT GONNA GO ALL RIGHT AND
THIS IS ALL GOING WHAT I
MENTIONED BELIEVES EARLIER IN
THE REMARKS GOVERNOR TO GIVE
HIS NAME ARE GOING TO BE ON
MOST IMPORTANT BECAUSE NOT GOT
USED TO SEEING- IMPORTANT THIS
IS WE ARE NOT GOING TO BE ON
THE OUT TO BE A LAW TO HELP
EXTREME PLAYED A LITTLE
EASEMENT AN IS GOING TO HAPPEN
JEANETTE IS WE ARE GOING TO SEE
TO OUR DATABASE ECONOMY THAT
ARE GONNA BE DRIVEN BY ONE OF
US IS GOING FABRIC THAT IS
PROVIDED BY THESE NEGATIVE RG
AND IT IS GOING TO BRING US
SPEED IT IS GOING BRING A MUCH
LOWER LATE MY ACCOUNT OF
COMMUNICATION DELAYS AND IT IS
GOING TO HELP US CONNECT MORE
DEVICES THE BEST TEAM AND ME
SAID DEVICES NOT JUST PEOPLE
THEY'RE TALKING ABOUT SENSORS
CAMERAS AUTONOMOUS CARS AND
OTHERS LIKE A WHOLE HOST OF
DEVICES THAT YOU NORMALLY
WOULDN'T THINK OF USING A
NETWORK BUT ALL OF THESE ARE
GOING TO BE CONNECTED. AND THAT
ENTIRE ECOSYSTEMS GOING TO
CHANGE HOW WE ALL ARE GONNA GET
ARTICLES VERY MANIFESTING IN
CYBER SECURITY IS GOING TO BE-
EVOLVE EVOLVING OVER TIME.
RIGHT NOW AT THE KEY PART FOR
MANY OF YOU ARTICLES AUDIENCE
HERE WOULD LIKE TO KNOW IS WHAT
IS THE IMPACT ON THE ECONOMY
AND DID I GUESS THAT IT'S GOING
TO LEAD TO START TRANSFORMATION
THE DIFFERENT SECTORS. BUT ONE
OF THE KEY PLAYERS AND IT IS
GOING TO HAPPEN. IS BECAUSE
FIGHT IN THE COURTS ARE GOING
TO COST. LOWER IN ORDER TO GET
BY THE BRITISH WIRELESS
NETWORKS MAINLY BECAUSE OF THE
BALLOT SHIFT IN HOW THESE OF
UNDERHOOKS I'M GOING FORWARD
WHERE HARDER HOUSTON HIS BIG
CUSTOMERS BOB THAT RUN BY
ESTATE FUEL THAT HAD TO GET
THESE COST MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
AND THIS WOULD INCREASE COST OF
DEPLOYING A INTERNET AND IF I
MANY ALL WOULD NOT A GOOD THE
NEXT FORWARD BECAUSE AFTER THE
REVENUE JUSTIFY THE HIKE OF
INVESTMENT THEY ROB AND. HI
JAMES SWITCHING TO MODEL GRADE
SCHOOL TO SUCK FOR SOME DEFINED
NETWORK AND LOOKS WHAT IS OUR
CAR KEEP DO CONSERVE THAT ARE
UNDERLINE FAIR PLAY ACROSS BUT
AND THEY'RE ALSO OPENING THE
NECK THE NATIONAL RELAXES
NETWORK IS ALSO US TO AB BUT
DEFINED INTERFACE THAT ANYBODY
CAN COME ON THE US OFFICE FOR
THE PIECES THE NETWORK IS STILL
THE DALLAS PART THE VERY CAN OF
IT LAST WEEK NOT YOU KNOW
INCOME PEOPLE TO GET UP AND VP
RIGHT YOUR CYLINDRICAL GETS
PROBABLY ONE TO BE CAN YEARS OR
WANT TO DO FIGHT IT. BECAUSE
THAT CYCLE AND SPEED WE CAN GET
FOSTER UPDATES A SOFTWARE BASED
IT BRINGS MORE VALUE OKAY IT'S
CLERK NEXT BE PLUGGED CAN BE A
PROBLEM ALL THEY'LL OPEN
NETWORK AND IF YOU A TO SEE
THAT I DON'T YOU CORRECT YOU
CAN WRITE SOFTWARE THE PLUG
THOSE HOLES AND THIS NECKLACE
MODEL AND SECURE. SO GOD ALL ON
THOSE BEING SOFT BASED ON THOSE
LAWS TO GET BECAUSE FINDING IT
AS YOU MENTIONED EARLIER ABOUT
SOME OF THE HOSPITALS EXCUSED
ARE FOR AS FAR ARE HAVING A
SMART BECAUSE BUSINESS OR AND
IF YOU BILL NETWORK SO ALL OF
THOSE THINGS ARE TO DOWNLOAD BY
ADDING A SOFT BUSINESS PUBLIC
WHICH REDUCES THE BAY TO ENTRY
BY LOOKS HEALTHCARE WELCOME ON
ALSO CALL LOWER BUT SO THAT IS
THE BIG IMPACT ON SOCIETY THE
DEADLINE TO SEE I'M FINDING
THAT OUT I JUST WANT TO KNOW OF
THIS WHEN I SAY SOCCER DEFINING
IS ALL PART OF OUR MOST READ
FORM WILL GET AND TO BOOKS ON
JUST GOING TO BE BAKING THIS
FROM THE DESIGN MAKING DESIGNS.
NOT MANY THE PIZZA I THINK MOST
OF YOUR HEALTH FOR FIVE G.
NETWORK BENEFITS IN TERMS OF I
AM SPEEDS LOWER LATER LARGER OF
DEVICE THIS START OF A YOU KNOW
ALL DID WAS DRUG THAT MAKES IT
THEN I SPEED UP THERE SEEING
BIG OR IN THE CAR FUNDS BUT THE
OTHER I GO WITH A NICE GUY OVER
TIME AND HE'S FOR THAT IS IT IS
NOT ONE STAR YOU NEED TO DO TO
LEAST ONE DAY OUTSIDE HE GETS
G. IT IS AS IT'S AN EVOLUTION
EVERY. WE ARE. ANYTHING MORE OF
THIS FEATURE BENEFITS OF FIVE
G. ALSO THAT IS AN IMPORTANT
THING TO KEEP IN MIND THAT THE
ECONOMIC BENEFITS ARE GOING TO
BE REALIZED OVER TIME AS THE
STANDARDS THEMSELVES- ONE CAR
MORE OFFICE FEATURES THAT HAVE
BEEN PUBLIC ABOUT US FIND
BENEFITS OKAY BUT THE KEY IS
BECAUSE SOFTWARE THESE YEAH
EVEN SOMETHING TO BE DEPLOYED
TODAY AND BE A FAN QUICKLY TO
NEW OUR STAFF AND MUCH LOWER
THE IN TERMS OF THE IMPACT HERE
INTERESTS TIDBIT THAT WOULD
LIKE TO POINT THAT THIS IS THE
SUSPECT IMPACT ON THESE BY THE
END OF TWENTY TWENTY. RIGHT THE
NUMBER OF BOB ARE YOU CONNECTED
THINGS THAT USED TO SELECT WORK
THE WIRELESS INTERNET TO PAY
ARE YOU INTERNET UP THAT I
SENSE CAN I CAN ONLY A CAR
LAUNCH SINCE. THEY HAD EXCEEDED
THE OF HE BEINGS THE PLANET AND
NUMBER IS GOING TO KEEP
TROUBLING IN THE NEXT YEARS
THANK THAT'S A HUGE NUMBER OF
THERE WAS AS WELL IN SOME THE
TRUCK FROM THESE DEVICES IS
GOING TO. A MATTER OF THAT
SMARTPHONE AND THE COME AND
BEINGS I G. NETWORK AND OTHER
LIFE NETWORKS AND ALL THAT ARE
GOING BE THE CONNECTING BACK
THAT HE DID INFORMATION FROM
FLOWS NOT THE MACHINES TALKING
ABOUT OF IT THEY ARE TRYING TO.
PROVIDE INCOME SO THAT IT. HOW
DO WE AND MACHINE AND I HAVE
CAN DATA STREAM FROM DEVICES I
AND ALSO PROVIDING TO PEOPLE
WHO ARE CONNECTED RIGHT SO I
CAN LOOK AT PHARMACY CAN I CAN
LOOK AT A SAY BETTER THERE'S A
WATER PROBLEM I NEED TO THERE'S
A RIGHT I GET ALL UNDERSTAND
THAT THE IS GETTING CUT
VALENTINE I AND I COULDN'T STOP
LOOKING AT THIS COULD POLLUTION
SAID WHAT KIND OF TO NEED TO IN
REAL TIME SO ALL OF THE INTO IS
TO HELP THE INTO KEEP COMPANIES
TWO THREE A GAIN AGREE OF A OF
ON REACT MANY QUICKLY ENOUGH
DEPLOYED PROPERLY RIGHT THESE
NETWORKS LOOK AND THOUGH
DIGITAL QUITE AND THEY CAN
BRING ABOUT MORE EQUITY AND
INCLUSIVE IN THE SOURCE SAID
OUTCOMES THAT GO HOPEFUL RIGHT
I JUST DON'T BECAUSE THESE
SENSORS ARE GOING TO BE
GENERATED SO MUCH ON DATA CAN
BE NEEDED FAST BECAUSE ALL FOR
PROCESS IT DRY QUESTION OF WHO
OWNS THESE HOLE IN OKAY THIS
GET A BACK BE L. WHAT HAPPENS
PURPOSE OF FUEL WORRY WHAT AND
THESE ARE THE TO THE NEW TO BE
AT AS SPOTS I DON'T CAN BE IF
LONG AND PICK MAS'S BUT TO GET.
IN ORDER ALSO PROJECT TO BE
FUNDED GOOGLE'S INTENT- I. FIVE
UTILIZAM GETTING MORE WIDER
SPECTRUM TO DELIVER THE HIGH
SPEEDS AND THAT IS CURRENTLY
ACHIEVED BY TURNING SPENT WITH
OTHER INCOME WELL WHO HAVE BEEN
ASSIGNED THAT COULD SPECTRUM
BANDS AND STUFF MOST MOST
SHOWED WASN'T GOING UP OVER MY
SUCH PROGRAMS THAT S. FUNDING
OF LAST EIGHT YEARS AND MANY
PRO THAT PEOPLE TALK ABOUT NAY
FIVE G. ON USE OF PEOPLE HE'S
COMMITTED EARLIER THIS WHICH
WAS USED ASKED ABOUT SOLUTION
FOR I DID IT BY SUCH AS AT
STUFF CAL SANTA BARBARA AND YOU
NEED AND WHAT YOU MEMBERS
THROUGH S. OF THAT SO UP AGAIN
WENT BACK TO THE DATA OUR MOST
OF PRIVACY HOW COME ON DATA ON
WHY THINK THE PRIVACY OF IN A
BIG PROBLEM AND WHAT DONE NEXT
WAS SUPPORTED BY AN S. ATTACHED
LETTER DOLLAR OF THE NOR UP
HALLMARKING ENCRYPTION IT'S ALL
THOSE YOU TO WORK DATA VIDEO
THAT YOU GET OUT FROM UNDER
ASPECTS OF THE SO THE F. TO BE
A CRITICAL OF I DO CLOSEST I
I'M NOT GONNA SB- FORMA
COMPANIES GOOGLE ALL COME AND
YOU KNOW ARE HARD TO DO A THING
TO YOU KNOW ENSURE THAT THE
JAPANESE THE GET AND THE FOR
THAT DOES NOT THE COMMITTEES
GOING FACE AS TO BUY MATURE I
KNOW OVER SO NOW I'M GOING TO
MY OKAY FROM QUALCOMM AFTER UP.
SOMEBODY CANNOT WOULD
APPRECIATE THAT BUT LET ME
PROCEED WITHOUT. SOMETHING THAT
WE CAN HELP. WE'RE GONNA TRY TO
MAKE THAT WORK BUT- IN THE
MEANTIME YOU FEEL LIKE TO
PROCEED FEEL FREE TO DO SO
PLACE IT SEEMS LIKE IT'S- IT'S
WORKING NOW IS WORKING OUT OKAY.
OKAY CAN YOU SEE THIS HONECKER
YES YES WE CAN YES THANK YOU
VERY MUCH WE GET GREAT IT
ALWAYS HAS TO HAVE A VISUAL
CUES I'M A VISUAL LEARNER AND I
BELIEVE WE'LL START SO I THINK
YEAH I GUESS SAID YOU KNOW IT'S
THERE ARE WONDERFUL THAT YOU'RE
HAVING THIS HEARING AT A VERY
ABOUT MARTINEK TIED OR THE FIVE
GW TO TAKE PLACE AND JUST ABOUT
BLAKE AND EXPECT AND AS
EXPLAINS WELCOME BEING IN THE
BUSINESS OF DOING WIRED INSIDE
INCEPTION WE B. R. THE WILD
COMPANY AND IT'S AN IDEA AND
WE'VE BEEN WORKING IN IT SINCE
TWO THE G. BUT FEEDING YOU G.
AS DIFFERENT FROM ANY OTHER
GENES ARE GENERATIONS OF FIRE
NEXT IN THE PAST. BOB BECAUSE
IT'S A PADDED AND SHIPPED WHILE
FROM ONE G. TO MG TO THREE G.
FOUR G. B. DESIGN THE SYSTEM
FOR CONNECTING PEOPLE TO PEOPLE
FIVE G. IS DESIGNED TO CONNECT.
THINGS TO THINGS AND THAT'S WHY
I THINK IT'S NOT AN
OVERSTATEMENT TO SAY THAT FIVE
G. SO WE CAN BE PART OF THE
DRIVE EVERY WHO WON'T BE EVENT
EVERY APPLIANCE WE USE EVERY.
DEVICE YOU IT IS GO TO BE A
COMMUNICATE BRAG FOR MODEL AND
THEREFORE THEY COULD TELL
RENEWALS REALLY ROADS WATER AND
ENERGY OFF KIND OF OFTEN NATION
BECAUSE THAT IS THE KIND OF
STRUCTURE AND PEOPLE ASK US
WHAT A FIVE G. LET ME QUICKLY
DOWN TO THREE BASIC THINGS THAT
IS FINE FOR THE INDUSTRY WHAT
IS FIVE G. AND EVERYTHING FLOWS
DROPPED NUMBER ONE IT'S
ENHANCED MORE BY IT BROADBAND
FASTER SPEEDS THAN YOU HAVE
EVER SEEN BEFORE MAKING YOUR
VIDEOS STREAM NOT DRESSED IN
OUR VIDEO CHAT BY BEING ABLE TO
STREAM GAMES AND LYFT IN
STADIUMS HAVING ACTUAL
CAPABILITIES FOR AUDIO- BARBARA
BUSH HAVE VIRTUAL REALITY AND
AUGMENTED REALITY ON YOUR GAS
HAS BEEN NOW DELAYS WITHOUT
INTERRUPTIONS SEAMLESS
EXPERIENCES- IT ALSO MEANS
MASSIVE INTERNET OF THINGS
EVERYTHING CONNECTED ABBIE
THEY'RE SMALL SENSORS IN
ELECTRICAL GRIDS IN HOSPICE AND
MANUFACTURING STATIONS THAT CAN
CONNECT TO- THAT CAN CREATE
DENSE NETWORKS IN SMART CITIES
AND PARKING LOTS AND MOST
IMPORTANTLY MISSION CRITICAL
SERVICES VERY NO DELAY I'M
GONNA ONE SECOND THAT'S LESS
THAN THE FLASH OF A CAMERA TO
TRANSMIT ONE PACKET FROM ONE
POINT TO ANOTHER VERY YOU VERY
HIGH RELIABILITY SIX NINE
NINETY NINE POINT NINE NINE
NINE NINE NINE NINE PERCENT.
WHICH MAKES POSSIBLE USING THIS
COMMUNICATION TECHNOLOGY PARTY
ANY CRITICAL FEED SERVICES LIKE
FACTORY AUTOMATION OUR REMOTE
HEALTH CARE AND SYNERGY ARE
CONNECTED CARS BECAUSE YOU
CANNOT MODERATE. ANY LOSS AND
ANY DELAY. IN THOSE
APPLICATIONS THAT HAVE TO DO
WITH SAFETY M. DOT IS FIVE G.
BAQI WELL FUNDAMENTAL
REVOLUTION THAT A MASSIVE
ECONOMIC IMPACT NOW AND WELCOME
IN PARTNERSHIP WITH ACCENTURE
WE TRIED TO ARTICULATE WHAT IS
THAT ECONOMIC IMPACT BY STUDY
PROBLEM SEVENTEEN DIFFERENT
INDUSTRIES ARE GOING TO DRAWS
FROM FROM MANUFACTURING TO
HEALTHCARE TO RETAIL ETCETERA.
AS FIVE G. IS TAKING BEING
TAKEN UP AND ADOPTED BY THESE
INDUSTRIES AT THE IMPACT IS
IT'S TO SEVEN TRILLION DOLLARS
JUST IN SALES FORCE STARTED
TRACKS AIMED AT US GDP ONLY IN
THE NEXT FIVE YEARS IN A POST
PANDEMIC ECONOMY ONE POINT FIVE
TRILLION DOLLARS OFF NEW GDP
AND UP TO SIXTEEN MILLION
ADDITIONAL JOBS ARE AND- THAT
CAN BE EITHER CREATED OR
TRANSFORM AS BETTER JOBS WE
ALSO TRYING TO UNDERSTAND WHAT
WOULD BE THAT IMPACT ON A
STATEWIDE BASIS AND WE HAVE
MORE INFORMATION FOR BREAKDOWN
OF CALIFORNIA IF DESIRED. BUT
AS YOU CAN SEE BOTH IN TERMS OF
THE GDP IMPACT AND JOBS NOT
SURPRISINGLY THE IMPACT OF ON
CALIFORNIA IS LIKELY TO BE THE
HIGHEST AND THAT'S BECAUSE OF
THE NATURE OF OUR ECONOMY IT'S
ONE OF THE LARGEST IT'S OUR
HIGH TECH ECONOMY IT HAS
MANUFACTURING AGRICULTURE.
RETAIL AND MANY OTHER
INDUSTRIES THAT COULD BE
IMPACTED BY FIVE G.
CONCENTRATED IN CALIFORNIA AND
THESE ARE THE KINDS OF
INDUSTRIES BY ARE THEY LEVEL UP
IMPACT THAT WE ARE SEEING ARE
YOU TALKING TRIED G. AS IT
TRANSFORMS THESE INDUSTRIES OF
COURSE PRIMARILY INFORMATION
AND COMMUNICATION TECHNOLOGY
YOUR DEVICES BY DEVICES ERP ARE
CLASSES THAT SET UP. ANOTHER
BIT OF THOSE AND I WOULD BE
ALSO READ A FACT IS NOT A FAR
BEHIND MARCH MANUFACTURING IS
DESIRED BY FACTORY FLOORS BACK
WANT GO WIRELESS IN THEIR
AUTOMATED FLOW SO THAT THERE'S
LESS DOWNTIME WHEN DID
RECONFIGURING THEIR FLOORS
REALLY NEEDING TO SIGNIFICANT
ECONOMIC GAINS AND BETTER
HIGHER THAN JOBS- FOR THOSE
WORKING IN THE MANUFACTURING
SECTOR I AGREE TO GO
PROFESSIONALS VIA ESTATE ORDER
FINANCE HEALTH CARE CALL
CONSTRUCT IN AGRICULTURE
EVERYTHING EDUCATION IS SEEING
AN IMPACT . AS RIGHT HE'S
TRANSFORM. I'M GOING TO CHECK
WITH YOU A LITTLE BIT ABOUT WHY
BUT LET ME ALSO SHARE WITH YOU
SOMETHING NEAR AND DEAR TO US
IN CALIFORNIA WHICH IS THE
STANDARD BENEFITS OF FIVE G.
GIVE LOOKED HARD AT THE DATA
AND YOU KNOW WE'VE TALKED AT
LENGTH WITH ENGINEERS. WHO
DESIGNED FIVE G. AND IT'S
ALWAYS VERY IS TRYING TO USE
LESS ENERGY FOR MORE OUTPUT FOR
MORE OPTIMIZATION SO WE HAVE
SEEN THAT BE I REALLY GOING TO
BE ABLE TO DEAL WITH ADMISSIONS
AND POLLUTION AND INCREASE
ENERGY EFFICIENCY AS MORE AND
MORE DEVICES MORE TO FIVE G.
EVERYTHING OUT OF ME. COMPARED
TO FORTY AND PREVIOUS. NEXT
LET'S NOW I IN TERMS YOU DEMAND
WHAT IS IT THAT TESTING WHAT DO
THEY WANT ME COME DOWN IT COMP
SURVEY ACROSS THE UNITED STATES
YOU AND THE REASON WE DIDN'T IS
PEOPLE TO WONDER IS FOR G.
IMPACT AND IS IN POST WILL BE
TO CONTACT ME AND THEY FOUND
THE ON TO BE OVER VENDING
CONNECT IS THE ANY OF THE FRONT
EXPECTATION IT IS SEEN AS
CENSURE IN OPPOSED WILL BE
KANEMI PEOPLE ABOUT FROM AND
SOMETIMES NEED TO EDUCATE THEIR
CHILDREN I CONSUMERS AREN'T ONE
THEY NEED AND OF THEY WANT
SMALLER THEY THEY THEY HAVE
WIREIMAGE ARE FLOW. HAVING THE
CONNECTIVITY IN AND OUT THE AND
EVERY TO PAY FOR IT AND YOU
WOULD CONSUMERS RECOGNIZE THAT
THERE IS A YOU TO DO THAT NEEDS
TO BE UNDER AND I THINK G. HAS
OF YOUR THEIR SO QUICKLY YOU
KNOW R. AS CONNECTED DRILLINGS
NOT ONE A CITY NINETY SO
PERCENT OFF PEOPLE ONE GOING TO
IN THE HOME AS OPPOSED 279% I
THE THAT IS COMPARED TO THE
PAST AND ENOUGH WILL SPEND ANY
SO INTER DOES NOT A CRITICAL AT
THIS WANT TO BE TO TRY HOME OUR
CONSUMERS THERE NUYS THEIR
THERE ISN'T YOU TO DO BOTH IN-
ORDER TO ADD. AND THAT NEEDS TO
BE FIXED AND I THINK FIVE YEARS
OF YOUR IS THERE DONE MANY
STUDIES TO WONDER BECAUSE
UNIFIED D. HAS ABILITY TO PUT
REMOTE AND DO NOT AND WE MADE
LEAGUES ANTENNAS THE ARE NOW
THAT WAS TALKING ABOUT TWO
MINUTES I THANK REPEAT AND
MAYBE RIGHT G. THE PROGRAM
EIGHT. INTERNET REMOTE AREA I
DON'T START PERCENT LOWER THAN
FIXED SOLUTIONS WHY NEED TO BE
DONE AND. NEXT GENERATION
CONNECTIVITY BEING UP PATRIOTIC
IF YOU'RE FOR MOST CONSUMERS.
THEY'RE DOING THIS AS- AN
IMPORTANT ISSUE FOR OUR COUNTRY
TO HAVE. A LEAD AND INFLUENCE
AND CONTROL OVER NEXT
GENERATION OF CONNECTIVITY SO
I'M I'M GOING TO SKIP A COUPLE
OF SLIDES BECAUSE THAT'S
READING TALKING ABOUT DIFFERENT
INDUSTRIES AND WHAT DID YOU
WHAT THE MOST IMPORTANT GETS
GETS ITS FOR FIVE G. THANK YOU
TO. HE'S ON HEALTHCARE OR
MANUFACTURING. AND WHAT ARE THE
ADVANTAGES THAT THEY DID AYE
FROM FIVE G. LIKE MANUFACTURING
THINGS. AT INDUSTRY SECTORS
SEES THAT THEY WANT TO SEE A
2230% OVER A PRODUCTIVITY GAIN.
ONCE THEY MOVE TO FIVE G. AND
90% DEFECT DETECTION AND
THURMOND. CONSORT OF- METRICS
THAT HE CAME UP WITH AN FOR
FIVE G. IMPROVEMENTS ACROSS
INDUSTRIES. I THINK I WOULD
LIKE TO END WITH. POLICY
RECOMMENDATIONS THAT NEED TO
HAPPEN TO ME EVALUATION A
REALITY. TO MAKE THIS TWENTY
TWENTY ONE TO TWENTY TWENTY
FIVE TRANSITION IN FIVE G.
ACROSS ECONOMIES AND INDUSTRY
SECTORS IN CALIFORNIA. NUMBER
ONE. YOU MUST RECORD THAT
BRANDY IN IN THESE TECH YEAH
HARD INDEED INTENSIVE WITH
FRIENDS BECAUSE ATTENDEES AND
ENTER PROPERTY ME TO BOND TO BE
ABLE TO COMPETE THIS ARE IN THE
IN GOING BECAUSE YOU NEVER WE
ARE A MARKET DRIVEN ECONOMY
BEYOND GETTING CAUGHT IN THE
FUNDING- FROM STATE SUBSIDIZED-
GRANTS FOR THE MOST PART WE ARE
FINDING OURSELVES BASED ON
DECEIVING. ARE A MONETIZATION
FROM LICENSING OUR INTELLECTUAL
ASSETS ACROSS THE IN BE MUST
ENSURE THAT THE WIRELESS THE
STUDY THE SEMI CONDUCTOR
INDUSTRY REMAINS RESILIENT THE
SUPPLY CHAIN SHOCKS RIGHT NOW
EVERYBODY HAS HEARD OF
SEMICONDUCTOR SHORTAGES ACROSS
INDUSTRIES MORE BY IS THE
LARGEST USER OF SEMICONDUCTOR
PRODUCTS IF THERE IS A GLOBAL
SUPPLY CHAIN DESTRUCTION THAT
WOULD CRIPPLE RIGHT AND WE'RE
GOING TO THE FIVE YEAR ADDITION
NUMBER NETWORK NEED TO BE
DEPLOYED AND BENT OUT NOT JUST
TRADITIONAL NETWORKS OF TRONG
YOU DON'T TAKING A ONE STOP
SHOP FROM LONG BIG
INFRASTRUCTURE PROVIDERS BUT
ALSO EMBRACING A REVOLUTION
THAT IS HAPPENING IN THE
INFRASTRUCTURE SPECIES WHAT
OPEN OTHER WORDS YOU'RE NOT HIS
NECKLACE THAT IS ABLE TO CREATE
AN ECONOMY OF THOUSANDS OF
DIFFERENT COMPONENT PROVIDERS.
THAT CAN SUPPLY DIFFERENT
COMPONENTS FOR CREATING THE
FIVE G. NETWORKS AND THEREFORE
NEED NOT RELIGION AND I THINK
THE FIVE G. INFRASTRUCTURE
ECONOMY. I WILL STOP HERE AND
HOPE THAT BIG THIS WAS
INFORMATIVE AND THAT THERE WILL
BE QUESTIONS FROM THE. ASSEMBLY
FOR. OKAY THANK YOU VERY FOR
YOUR LET US NOW GO TO COURT YOU
A BUT I INITIALLY THAT PART OF
MY INITIAL- REMARKS- WAS NOT
PICKED UP BY THE AUDIO SO I'M
GOING TO REPEAT SOME OF WHAT I
SAID EARLIER- FOR THOSE OF YOU
WHO LIKE TO CALL IN- PLEASE-
THEIR NUMBER IS EIGHT SEVEN
SEVEN. SIX NINE TWO EIGHT NINE
FIVE SEVEN AND THE ACCESS CODE
IS ONE THREE ONE FIVE FOUR
THREE SEVEN. AGAIN THE PUBLIC
COMMENT LINE IS. 877-692-8957
AND- SO WITH THAT LET'S OPEN UP
THE QUEUE IN A- PORTION. I
THINK THAT THE INFORMATION HAS
BEEN VERY HELPFUL AND YOU KNOW
IT PARTICULARLY WITH RESPECT TO
ONE OF THE EXAMPLES THAT THE
PANEL IS. PROVIDED AND THAT
NUMBER IS STAGGERING AND THE
THESE EXAMPLE DAD THAT WAS
GIVEN WAS THAT THE NUMBER OF A
MOBILE DEVICES OR I'LL I'LL TWO
DEVICES- IS GOING TO EXCEED.
THE NUMBER OF HUMAN BEINGS ON
THIS WORK ON THIS- EARTH AND-
THAT NUMBER IS EXPECTED TO
TRIPLE IN THE NEXT TWO YEARS
AND THAT THAT'S SO VERY
STAGGERING NUMBER. SO THAT GOES
TO SHOW HOW IMPORTANT- IT YOU
KNOW IT IS TO FORCE TO BRICK
BUILD A FRAMEWORK SO WITH THAT
IN MIND I HAVE A COUPLE OF
QUICK QUESTIONS FOR THE
PANELISTS. FIRST QUESTION BEING
THAT DUE TO THE PREDICTED
ECONOMIC PROJECTIONS FORESHADOW
A LINEARIZED IN ECONOMIC
ACTIVITY OR IS IT MORE OF A
CURVED. AND EVEN RICE ANY OF
THE ANY OF THE PALACE SO FEEL
FREE TO CHINA. DID YOU WANT TO
THE POST AB I BELIEVE THAT WITH
EVERY G. THE RISE IS NOT YOU
SEE THAT EARLY ADOPTION IS NOT
BE FREE BUT HAVE SKEPTICISM AND
THAT IS SOME TENTS AND BUILDING
OUT ACTORS THAT IS SOME
BARRIERS TO- THE INITIAL EXAM
COSTS BUT MONTHS SPENT EVERY
GENERATION WE HAVE SEEN THIS
ONCE THAT. OUT IN THE SHOWS
TRUMP IS OVERCOME YOU SEE AN
EXPONENTIAL RISE AND BULLETS
THE INCREASE THE NUMBER OF
DEVICES THAT HAVEN'T HAD
MENTIONED INCREASED- SO MUCH
THAT IT EXCEEDED THE BARD
POPULATION IN THE LAST FEW
YEARS JUST SMARTPHONES AND YEAH
I KNEW IT WAS AND THEREFORE
GROWTH I BELIEVE THAT BEARD TO
SEE THE SAME THING THAT FIVE G.
BUT I DOES WE HAVE NEVER SEEN
BEFORE BECAUSE IT IS GOING TO
TOUCH MANY MORE INDUSTRIES THAN
ANY PREVIOUS GENERATION I WILL
CALL WHAT. A CONTESTING AND I
THINK THAT WHAT I SAID EARLIER
ABOUT THE I DO NOT BEING A
SINGLE STANDARD AT SOUTHERN
UTAH ON THE SWITCH ON AND
SEVENTY HAPPENS THE SAME PART
OF PART OF THAT DESCRIPTION
WHAT IS PART IS FIVE G. C.
STANDARDS AND- HE'S TALKING
SOMETHING FUTURE AND SOME
FEATURES THAT ARE GOING TO. A
NEW SENSE OF THAT BILL DOES
FEATURES ARE ASSEMBLY ON THE
AND I ARAMBULA TALK A LITTLE OF
WATER IN THE NEXT SESSION BUT
YOU KNOW THAT. LAYING ON OF
HANDS RIGHT BEYOND WHAT NETFLIX
BECAUSE OF THE POINT RIGHT ARE
YOU VIDEOS WE DON'T KNOW DO YOU
PLAY MORE OF THE BETTER SPEEDS
YES YOU CAN CONNECT PEOPLE
MIGHT BE CAN GET MORE WORK SO
BUT IT DOES NEED TO IMMEDIATE
BUT THE OTHER FEATURES OF FIVE
G. THE DALLAS IN THE NEXT TO
THREE STAND. DODD WILL NEED
WHICH SO WHAT MAY SEE LIKE WHAT
BE SETTING IT JUST YEAR'S
THIRTY OR SOMETHING ELSE TO GO
CONCERNED HUGE AND THEN WOULD
BE COME ABOUT VENDORS
APPLICATIONS ARE TESTED AND
VIDEO ON THE ROLE ENOUGH THAT
COULD SUDDENLY BECOME MUST
MARKET RIGHT AND IT ALWAYS SO I
CAN GO TO THE DOCTOR ABOUT
ACCESS AND DON'T FORGET NAY DO
WE SEE GAINES GOING THE PARTS
OF SOCIETY EQUITY RIGHT TO DIE
IS IMPORTANT PART BECAUSE I
THINK THE BILL BIG FIVE G. IS
TO THE COST OF BROAD IS GOING
TO BE A PART OF THE MORE TO GO
OVER SOME OF BROADBAND THE
BAKER BE A EQUITY ARE INTENSE
WANTS CHRISTMAS ALL SIX OF THE
POPULATION HAVE TO SERVICE AND
BUILD ON THIS GOING TO BE.
FIVE. THANK YOU VERY THE SECOND
I TO DEAL SO SOMETHING THE PARA
HAS STILL I TOUCHED ON A LITTLE
BIT AND QUESTION BEING THAT
WITH G. NOT K. OF VASTLY MORE
MORE DATA THAN BEFORE HOW DO
FIVE G. C. ENSURE THEY'RE SICK
I THINK THAT MENTIONED THE
PRIME ISSUE IS AN HAS BEEN
CHALLENGING IT'S CHALLENGING
ONE SO I'M WONDERING WHETHER
YOU COULD DOUBT YOU KNOW TOUCH
ON A LITTLE BIT EVEN MORE.
ABOUT SECURITY AS WELL AS
PRIVACY THANK YOU. I'LL TAKE A
PASS THIS MONTH- IF YOU CAN
MAKE. SURE SO. I THINK ASPECTS
TO SECURITY YEAH RIGHT WHEN WE
TALK ABOUT. SECURING THE
NETWORK MOST OF SECURING THE
DATE. THANKS FOR THE NETWORK
ITSELF IS THE PART THAT. MAKES.
YOU IN PLACE ASIANS THE SERVER
IN THE BACK OF RIGHT AND THAT
BACK AND FOR IS FORM SECURE AND
I THINK PART OF THE ART MANY
SECURITY OUT THAT HAVE BEEN IN
PREVIOUS GENERATION OF NETWORK
AND WHAT FIVE G. HAS DONE IS TO
AGREE A MUCH ROBUST DESIGN.
MULTIPLE OPTIONS TO ACHIEVE
REALLY DEBATE TITLED A SINGULAR
SOME OF THOSE THINGS JOBS COME
A COST OF BUT FAR ENOUGH INTO
IN THE US I USED NETWORK I
THINK FIVE G. IS ONE THOSE CAN
THAT IS GOING BE MUCH MORE
SECURE IS DEEPLY OPTICAL TO
THOSE PLACE OPTION ANY GENDER
MEDICAL GET SEEN WITH RIGHT NOW
ALL THE BAR ABOUT WHAT THE DAY
SO THAT'S THE DIFFERENCE TO
THANKS BYE IS WHY I WOULD THINK
ABOUT US POLICY REQUEST OUR
PRIVACY OF DATA A HOW DO THESE
STORE ARE SECURE THAT DATE IT
MAY NOT HAVE ANYTHING THE NEXT
ITSELF RIGHT AND MAYBE MORE OF
WELL I DON'T THINK AND- PEOPLE
LIKE IN THE GET ON OTHER SIDE
SO THAT'S THE TYPE A DIFFERENT
BUT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
EARLIER WE LOOKED AT MAP OF ALL
THIS IN IN THE IN THE COUNTRY
ARE WHEN IT COMES TO DEPLOYMENT
OF FIVE G. SO I GUESS THE
QUESTION IS HOW DOES WELL I
GUESS OF THE FIRST IS HOW HOW
DOES THE UNITED STATES COME
STACK UP AGAINST LET'S SEE THE
REST OF THE COUNTRY WHEN IT
COMES TO A DEPLOYMENT OF FIVE
G. YOU KNOW WE HAVE NOTICE OF
FROM THE FROM THE GROUT THAT
CALIFORNIA IS BASICALLY IN THE
BASICALLY THE FRONT RUNNER-
COMPARED TO OTHER STATES AND
THEN I ALSO PRESUME THAT- YOU
KNOW THIS DEPLOYMENT IS A MAJOR
PART OF THE- WITHOUT
CALIFORNIA'S ECONOMY. AND IS
VERY COMPETITIVE IN CARING
CALIFORNIA'S BUT BUT THE
QUESTION BEING THAT YOU KNOW
HOW HOW WELL THIS UNITED STATES
A STACK UP AGAINST OTHER
COUNTRIES WHEN IT COMES TO
DEPLOYMENT OF FIVE G. GREAT
QUESTION. THAT DROP THANK YOU
ALL SAW OF THE UNITED STATES
ACROSS STATE WAS AN ESTIMATED
POTENTIAL ECONOMIC GAIN. ACROSS
STATES. IF FIVE G. IS DEPLOYED
IN A TIMELY MANNER FROM TWENTY
TWENTY ONE TO TWENTY. FIVE IT
MAY NOT HAPPEN. IT'S UP TO US
TO MAKE IT HAPPEN APPLAUSE
DIFFERENT NATIONS- US IS IN THE
LEAD RIGHT NOW FOR DEPLOYMENT
BUT CHINA AND EUROPE AREN'T FAR
BEHIND IN CERTAIN TECHNOLOGIES
LIKE MILLIMETER RADIUS B. HAVE
A LEAD AND AN EXACT AGE AND WE
WANT TO CONTINUE TO KEEP IT
THAT WAY I IT'S LIKELY BASED ON
OUR PROJECTED ESTIMATE OVER THE
NEXT FIVE YEARS WE WILL
CONTINUE TO HAVE A LEAD IN THAT
ECONOMIC ATTRACT ACROSS
INDUSTRIES. JUST BECAUSE OF THE
NATURE AND SIZE OF OUR ECONOMY
AND INDUSTRIES. I'M GLAD THAT
THE FACT THAT THERE ARE MARKET
BASED ECONOMY MEANS THAT
ENTERPRISES AND COMPANIES IN
THE SPACE I HAVE EVERY
INCENTIVE TO STAY UP IS UP TO
PAR EVEN TRIED TO BEAT THE
COMPETITION. LOCALLY THANKS
AGAIN GOT ON THE U. S. A. IN
BULK AND PACKAGED. YES OTHER
COMPANIES ARE TRYING TO THE
OTHER COUNTRIES LIKE TRYING
REALLY HARD TO- TO CATCH UP OUR
TITLE OR BE THE LEAD BUT THE
FIRST STEP IN ADVANTAGE OF
ENTERING A MISSION. THAT I YEAH
AND THE CHEMICALS THAT IS THE
US BENEFITS HERE VERY GOOD
THANK VERY MUCH OUR TO THANK
THE TWO SO FOR YOUR PRESENTE
AND LET'S NOW GO TO OUR SECOND
PANEL. FOR THAT DATA. ARE WE
ARE FORTUNATE TO HOW LONG
JOINING US AGAIN DR NANDA
GOPAL- THE TOPIC OR SUB TOPIC
IS EMERGING TRENDS IN FIVE G.
AND SPECIFIC USE CASES JOINING
DR UNETHICAL PAUL. ARE ALSO- WE
HOW BY THE OF THE RUDY RAY S.
VICE PRESIDENT AND ASSOCIATE
GENERAL COUNSEL FOR THE
WESTERN. WITH FOR THE WEST
REGION AT VERIZON. AND THE
THIRD PANEL AS WE HOW THIS
CHRIS BOYER WHO IS THE VICE
PRESIDENT OF GLOBAL SECURITY
AND TECHNOLOGY POLICY AT A. T.
AND T. SO WELCOME AND IF YOU'RE
READY YOU MAY PLEASE BEGIN
LET'S START AGAIN WITH THE
DOCTOR NOW LOCAL PAUL THANK YOU
AGAIN AWESOME JOB AGAIN
PRIVILEGED TO BE HERE TO TALK
ABOUT THIS OTHER IN THAT TOPIC
THIS IS SOMEWHAT EMERGING
TRENDS IN FIVE G. AND SPECIFIC
USE USE CASES. I MENTIONED IN
THE EARLIER PART OF THE GETTING
BACK THE KEY FEATURES OF FIVE
G. R. INCREASED DATA SPEEDS.
REDUCE DELAYS INCREASED NUMBER
OF DEVICES. THAT CAN CONNECT TO
THE NETWORK AND THIS IS CALLED
CONNECTION DENSITY ALL THE
ALREADY HAD A LISTING THE
INCREASED IT HAS BEATS- WOULD
BE OUT IN THE US DOES NOT ON
AUGUST MORE GOING HAPPENED IN
FIVE G. UNDER TO. UP IN THE
DATA AND THE CONNECTION DENSITY
OF. ALL OF THE TWO. I BELIEVE-
THE ACTION DENSITY ESSENTIAL
THE SUPPORT LAW NUMBER OF
INTERNET OF THINGS DEVICES THAT
ARE GOING TO BE AND PROVIDING A
WITH THIS OF THAT NEXT FROM
THAT INCREASED HELLO SYNCING
MONITORING THE WITH THIS DEVICE.
ALL IN TERMS GIVING CHANGE
RIGHT I THINK OF WHAT THE ULTRA
LOW LEADER REALLY DEBT
COLLECTION IS GOING TO BE A
GAME CHANGER AND INCOMES MORE
BY FAX DAY SURGERY ARE
AUGMENTED CAN OF PUBLIC THIS
SOME THAT SOCIETY HAS SEEM
BEFORE I'M NOT ARE NOT TO THIS
IMAGINE BEING ABLE TO. BE
PHYSICALLY PRESS OR HOW TO FEEL
OF BEING PRESS AND IT IS NOT
LOCATION AND BEING ABLE TO AND
THE DOLLAR THE I'M NOT LAW THAT
YOU'VE VERY IN THAT SPACE WHEN
YOU PUT ON A PERSONAL DATA
HEALTH SO IT'S NOT A FUTURE AND
CAN BE ENABLED BY THIS SO MICRO
LONGER LATE ARBITERS ARE DUMB
AND GIVE FEATURE THAT IS IDEAL
SPREADING TO AND THAT WAS
TAKING STE FROM TWENTY TWENTY
TO. I'M NOT WE'VE DONE THE NEXT
START TO ALSO START BY. TWENTY
IS C. A. ACTION THE SEE
EXAMPLES FIND SECOND WHICH
WOULD THEN NEED TO SNAP AND I
DO BY IS IN MY IN ONE OF THE
DEFINING TREND THAT I AM
LOOKING FORWARD TO PERSON
THAT'S GOING TO CHIU HOW BE YOU
IN PERCEIVED THESE AND RELEASED
ON NEW APPS THAT NETWORK UP
WITH. THERE ARE MANY OTHER
NORMAL USE CASES MIGHT OFMY
ESTEEMED FELLOW BY ABILITY
SHEDDING AS I DON'T WANT TO DO
THAT THUNDER THEY'RE I WOULD
LIKE TO SHARE WITH SPECIFIC USE
CASE OF HIGH G. WHICH THE
PASSED UP ON BRIEFLY IN EARLIER
IN THE DAY SESSION HI THIS IS
DUONG HELP THE UNCONNECTED
THANK THIS THE IMPORTANT OF
BROAD ACCESS. BE STILL HAVE
MILLIONS ALSO AROUND THE I'M IN
THE STATE OF LACK ACCESS TO OF
THE IS FOR DOUBLE HI SPEED WHY
OF RIGHT AND THE RESIDENTS WHO
ARE LARGEST LET'S THE SPENT SO
THIS IS A SIGNAL CHALLENGES
SPANS BOTH URBAN AND RURAL
REGIONS OF STATE I ONE WOULD
LIKE TO THINK THAT WHY IS THIS
A FOR IN ONLY OTHER JUST IT'S
THE COUNTRY BUT I THINK THE
REAL CHIU IS THE LACK OF BLOOD
INFRASTRUCTURE IN MANY OF THE
REGIONS THE BIG A BARRIER I'M
IS THAT LACK OF BROADBAND ZERO
IT IS TO DEPLOY I THOUGHT I
SAID TODAY GONNA AND AGAIN I
DON'T OF THIS THE RETURN ON
INVESTMENT FOR GO A MUCH THAN
THAT OF BECOMES NATURAL BARRIER
SOMETIMES YEAH AND DOESN'T HAVE
MONEY CAN TO SO I KNOW BUT I
MENTIONED EARLIER FUTURE FIVE
NETWORKS THANK SO D. D. WOULD
BE MUCH INCOME BIG BY VIRTUE OF
SO BASED AND ALSO BEING CHEAP
TO ALL AND RUN GIVES A LOT FOR.
I MEAN ASPECT OF TECHNOLOGY ASK
THAT IT IS ABOUT FOUNDER IS
NOTIONAL INTENDED I AND BACK NO
BY ONLY WHILE NETWORK IS
CONNECTED BY A Y. ON THE BACK
MORE. THAN NOT A TWO OFFEND UP
CABLE FOR. THAT COMES A LITTLE
BIT THE BEST ACTION THE MOBILE
PHONE THAT WOULD BE A LOT OF
THE NOW THE RUNNING OF YOU NEED
TO GET RID CROSS AND CONFIRM IT
NOT THAT'S A THAT IS THAT IT
MAKES ME THE COST THE X.
DEPOSITS NETWORKS ONE FIVE
NETWORK STANDARDS ARE TRYING TO
DO IS GET TO BE INCORPORATED OF
THE TO ACCESS AND LET WAY BACK
CALL IT SEVEN FIVE THINK CAN BE
THANK YOU CAN BE THE LIGHT CAN
BE FOR WHAT PROTECTING YOURSELF
DIRECTLY AND ALSO YOU HAVE THIS
TO STOCK. OTHER BITS. THE
SCHOOL WE HAD TO ADDRESS. THE
CHALLENGES OF BROADBAND
CONNECTIVITY. PROVIDED LOTS OF
BAKER GLANCED ONTO TEAMS OF
COMMUNITY ORGANIZATIONS AND
CITY LEADERS TO REACH THEM
USING SOME OF THESE SERVICES
NOW BY JESUS THE GOING TO MAKE
IT EASIER TO DEPRIVED OF TO BE
DEPLOYED BE HARD- BEGIN IS
EXTREMELY IMPRESSIVE. ENABLE ON
THAT POINT. OR SOME OF THE
COLLECTIVE CHANCE MIGHT BE TO
SEE SIMILAR GAINS AGAIN.
REGIONS THAT ARE EXTREMELY RUDE
AND ALSO TRYING TO THE BEST SO
FOR EXAMPLE. BE FUNDED A
PROJECT OF CALIFORNIA SANTA
BARBARA WELL THE TRYING TO
PROJECT WHICH TRIES TO BRING
FOSTER ROBIN HOOD ACCESS USING
A RANGE OF SPECTRUM BANDS THAT
TRADITIONALLY ARE NOT USED. FOR
OTHER REGULAR FOOD UNIT. RIGHT
I THINK FIVE G. NETWORKS ARE
GOING TO BE INCORPORATING MANY
OF THOSE ASPECTS BOSTON
SHEDDING USING WHITE SPACES
AND- YOU KNOW OUR ADVICE AXLES
SO IN THE NAME A FEW TO
INCREASE THE AMOUNT OF SPECTRUM
OF THEIR FOR THE DEVELOPMENT OF
DATA THAT CAN BE CARRIED ON THE
STATE'S. ALL OF SARDO OF THE
CHALLENGE IS DOUBLE WHAT HAS
BEEN OF MORMON I MENTIONED THE
BACKLOG THE NEXT LOCAL SO CAN
BE BACK OF THE NAY BOOK IT'S
CAN BE LETTER LINKS WE NEED IN
TO ALLOW WHICH ON THAT ME RIGHT
SO ONE MAY I WHY DID TAKE SO
LONG TO FIGURE TO GET THAT WHAT
BACKHAUL WHAT NOT HAVE FOR G. I
DON'T HAVE A GOOD. DAY BYE HE'S
JUST MAKING A I G. B. ONE B.
TWO THAT ARE MORE OPTIONS WE
HAVE STAFF BEEN A BE A MINI
THIS OPTIONS ARE COMING. SB
GOING TO BE TESTING A RANGE OF
TECHNOLOGIES THAT ARE GOING TO
BE FOCUSING ON- STONES
PRECISION AGRICULTURE- INPUT
CROP AND LIVESTOCK. FARMS AND
THEY'RE ALSO GOING TO BE
LOOKING AT EDUCATION- OTHER
OPTIONS IN THE WORLD YES. WHAT
KIND OF ADVANCED AFFORDABLE
BROADBAND OPTIONS THAT MAY HELP
SO AND I THINK AS I MENTIONED
BEFORE AN EMERGING USE SB
SENATE HAS NOTHING LIKE THE
COLOR NO MATTER WHAT KIND USED
AS WE COME UP WITH WE NEED TO
MAKE SURE THAT IN THE EXTREME
DISRUPTIVE BUT DOESN'T TAKE US
ALL BACK TO THE STUDENTS RIGHT
A LESSON THAT I REMEMBER
DISTINCTLY FROM HOW TO
CONSOLIDATE YOU HAVE CITY WAS
IF YOU WHEN YOU LOST POWER. BUT
THREE DAYS BEAVER HELLO AND
THIS WAS LIKE CAN YEARS AGO AND
NOT IN THE IMAGINE THAT
HAPPENING TODAY AND THE STATE
OF OUR OFFENSE MAY. BE ONE
DOLLAR NETWORKS TO BE EXTENDING
HIS LEAD AND THIS IS GOING TO
BE A CRITICAL PIECE OF A FIVE
G. AND WHATEVER COMES NEXT. AND
THE LAUNCH OF THE JUST LAUNCHED
A NEW PROGRAM IN THE REGION
NEXT EXISTENCE PROGRAM ALL
GRAINS WHICH IS TRYING TO
ISOLATE ASSAD'S WILL HELP MAKE
OUR NETWORKS EXTREMELY
EXTREMELY RELIABLE AND
RESILIENT NO MATTER WHAT
HAPPENS AND YET THE L.
PARTNERSHIPS MANY COMPANIES
THAT ARE BASED IN CALIFORNIA
HOUSEHOLDS WILL X. AND- TO NAME
A FEW I AM THE END B. OVER AND
THE ARE HOPING TO SOME OF
SIERRA UP I'LL JUST I'M UP WITH
INTO OPTIONS MAKE A IDEA
SYSTEMS EXPERIENCE AND
RESILIENT SO THEY CAN DO ON THE
PROMISE THAT THE OFFERING US SO
VP THAT THE EMERGENCE UP JUST
GIVE OF G. R. ALL GOING TO COME
OVER THROUGH A STRONG OF BY
WORKING WITH AND COURSE I'LL
LOOKS LIKE AND NO TRYING TO
HOPE THAT AS I CAN BECAUSE AND
THE THING THAT THEY CAN HELP
SIGNATURE IN FACT I THINK THAT
WE SHOULD ALL REMEMBER TO MAKE
IT TO REMEMBER THE UNDER GET
AND THE DIGITAL DIVIDE I'VE
BEEN GOING ALL THESE THE
ADMISSION OF THE THERE ARE ALL
OF CITY EQUITY ACCOUNTED. I AM
GOING TO GO THROUGH THIS PANELS
ABOUT FIVE G. USE CASES I AM
GOING TO GO THROUGH WHAT WE
CALL THE EIGHT CURRENCIES ARE
FIVE G. WHAT MAKES IT SUCH A
TECHNOLOGY SO POTENTIALLY
TRANSFORMATIONAL ACROSS A RANGE
OF. CONSUMER BUSINESS
ENTERPRISE APPLICATIONS. I
DON'T WANT TO BURY THE LEAD.
AND I WANT TO SPEAK DIRECTLY TO
YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN AND THE
MEMBERS THE ASSEMBLY. WIRELESS
TECHNOLOGY. IS POISED TO SOLVE.
THE DIGITAL DIVIDE AND THE LAST
MILE PROBLEM IN
TELECOMMUNICATIONS. IN LARGE
PART. AND THIS HAS BEEN A GOAL.
OF TELECOMMUNICATIONS POLICY.
SINCE THE NINETEEN NINETY SIX
TELECOMMUNICATIONS ACT. WHERE
CONGRESS AND POLICYMAKERS
DREAMED OF A TIME. WHEN THE
MAJOR CARRIERS AND TECHNOLOGIES
WOULD COME TOGETHER. AND BE
ABLE TO COMPETE AGAINST ONE
ANOTHER. TO ACTUALLY SERVED-
UBIQUITOUSLY. AND I SAY THAT
WIRELESS TECHNOLOGY IS POISED
TO SOLVE THE LAST MILE. WORKS
TO SERVE- ARE OUR CITIZENS AND
OUR OUR PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA
AND AMERICA- D. BROADBAND
PROVIDERS. FOR THE LAST YOU
KNOW TWELVE YEARS OR LONGER.
HAVE BEEN AT OR NEAR THE TOP.
OF THE PROGRESSIVE POLICY
INSTITUTE'S AMIR AMERICAN
INVESTMENT HEROES LIST THE
COMPANIES THAT ARE INVESTING
THE MOST CAPITAL INVESTMENTS IN
AMERICA- IT'S VERY COSTLY TO
DIG UP THE STREETS THE
SIDEWALKS TO DEPLOY THE FIBER-
AND GET THESE- RADIO ACCESS
NETWORKS BUILT. UBIQUITOUSLY
AND SO WHATEVER WE CAN DO TO
LOWER THOSE COSTS TO SO THAT WE
CAN PUSH BROADBAND OUT TO
EVERYONE HAS ALWAYS BEEN THE
GOAL- TELECOMMUNICATIONS AT
LEAST SINCE THE NINETEEN NINETY
SIX TELECOMMUNICATIONS ACT. AND
TRADITIONALLY- WE YOU KNOW WE
DEAL WITH THE INCUMBENTS RIGHT
WE DO IT WITH YOU NOW WITH THE
INCUMBENT TELEPHONE OR
INCUMBENT LOCAL EXCHANGE
CARRIER YOU KNOW BUILDING-
FIBER- YOU KNOW- WHETHER IT'S
TO THE CURB TO THE PREMISE- YOU
DO IT THROUGH THE CABLE COMPANY
WHICH BUILDS COAXIAL. CABLE AND
THEY ALSO HAVE TO- WIRE THAT
ALL THE WAY TO THE END USERS
PREMISE RIGHT THE HOME OF THE
SMALL BUSINESS OR THE LARGE
ENTERPRISE. SO THE BIG- THE BIG
DEAL HERE IS THAT WIRELESS
TECHNOLOGY. WITH FIVE G. IS NOW
POLL TO ALLOW US TO DELIVER
THAT LAST MILE STREET THE
SIDEWALK. THE LAST MILE TO THE
CUSTOMER'S PREMISE WIRELESSLY.
OKAY NOW YOU MIGHT SAY HEY I
COULD DO THAT TODAY WITH FOUR
G. AND YES THAT'S TRUE FOUR G.
REALLY PAVED THE WAY FOR FIVE
G. TAKE YOURSELF BACK TEN YEARS
AGO WHEN FOUR G. WAS IN ITS
INFANCY PRIOR TO TEN YEARS AGO
WHEN WE WERE STILL MAILING DVDS
TO NETFLIX. OR AMAZON WAS JUST
BEING BORN AS A COMPANY AS AN
ONLINE SHOPPING PORTAL RIGHT IT
REGIONALLY SOLD BOOKS NOW WITH
FOUR G. AND THE MEGABIT LEVEL
CONNECTIVITY THAT IT GIVES YOU
ANYWHERE THERE IS A SIGNAL YOU
COULD STREAM NETFLIX WHEREVER
YOU COULD ORDER AMAZON WHEREVER
AMAZON WEB SERVICES HAS.
THRIVED IT'S A NEW TECHNOLOGY
ORGY IS TRANSFORMED OUR LIVES
FIVE G. IS GOING TO TAKE THAT
TO THE NEXT LEVEL SO AND THE
OTHER PART ABOUT FOUR G. IS THE
CAPACITY OF FOUR G. NETWORKS IS
LIMITED AND ITS CONSTRAINT. SO
WHILE TODAY YOU CAN GET YOUR
BROADBAND FROM LTE FOUR G. LTE
THERE'S ONLY SO MANY LANES ON
THE HIGHWAY RIGHT WHICH IS WHY
WE NEED SMALL CELLS TO BUILD
OUT THE CAPACITY ABOUT NETWORK
AND BUILD MORE LANES TO THE
FOUR G. LTE HIGHWAY. AS MORE
AND MORE PEOPLE USE THEIR
SMARTPHONES FOR VIRTUALLY
EVERYTHING BUT STILL THERE ARE
DATA CAPS THERE ARE LIMITS THAT
THE NETWORK PROVIDERS HAVE TO
PUT ON THE CAPACITY OF THAT
NETWORK SO THAT IT WORKS FOR
EVERYONE. CALLED NETWORK
MANAGEMENT FIVE G. WHAT MAKES
IT SO TRANSFORMATIONAL IS THE
SPECTRUM AND I'M GONNA GO TO
THE CURRENCIES THAT WERE USING
PLASTIC FIBER TRANSPORT IT BACK
CALL UPGRADES THAT ARE NEEDED.
ARE GONNA MAKE THOSE DATA CAPS
OF THING OF THE PAST. SO WITH
FIVE G. EVERYONE'S ASKING RIGHT
WHAT'S THE KILLER APP GOING TO
BE FOR FIVE G. IS GOING TO BE
SMART CITIES IS GONNA BE A. R.
B. R. IS GOING TO BE. BE ME UP
SCOTTY. IT'S GOING TO BE ALL OF
THOSE THINGS BUT THE TRUE
KILLER APP FOR RIGHT NOW IN
TWENTY TWENTY ONE IN THIS TIME.
IS BROADBAND FIVE G. IS GOING
TO DELIVER A THIRD HEIGHT IF
YOU WILL. FOR HOME AND SMALL
BUSINESS BROADBAND. IN
COMPETITION WITH THE INCUMBENT
TELEPHONE IN THE INCUMBENT
CABLE COMPANIES. SO THAT'S
THAT'S THE TRANSFORMATIONAL
POWER OF FIVE G. AND THE REASON
WHY IT'S A TRANSFORMATIONAL ARE
BECAUSE OF WHAT WE CALL THE
EIGHT CURRENCIES A FIVE YEAR
THE CAPABILITIES OF FIVE G. SO.
I YOU KNOW I WOULD SAY THAT
THIS SPECTRUM WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT MILLIMETER WAVE HIGH BAND
SPECTRUM OF MID BAND SPECTRUM.
IT'S NOT NEW WE HAVE BEEN
USING- MICROWAVE TRANSPORT. FOR
GENERATIONS AND
TELECOMMUNICATIONS TO TRANSPORT
LARGE AMOUNTS OF DATA FROM ONE
POINT TO ANOTHER WHERE IT'S
REALLY HARD TO BUILD FIBRE LIKE
OUT IN OUR RURAL COMMUNITIES-
ALONG. THREE NINETY FIVE- UP IN
NOR CAL OR ALONG THE COAST- UP
IN NOR CAL- BUT- AS A LAST MILE
TECHNOLOGY THAT IS WHERE FIVE
G. IS REALLY TRANSFORMATIONAL.
SO THE SPECTRUM WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT WITH FIVE G. BOTH THE MID
BAND SPECTRUM. WHICH IS THE
SUBTEXT GIGAHERTZ AND THEN THE
HIGH BAND SPECTRUM THE
MILLIMETER WAVE SPECTRUM. HAS
EIGHT CAPABILITIES- THAT ALSO
DEPEND ON HAVING A ROBUST
FIBER. BACKHAUL AND TRANSPORT
YEAH SEVEN NOT MATT HOW THIS
SIGNAL GETS TO YOU IT'S JUST
THE LAST MILE THAT IS WIRELESS
THE MIDDLE MILE AND THE FIRST
MILE IS ALL FIBER MASSIVE
AMOUNTS OF FIBER SO WE USED TO
DEPLOY FIBER CABLES AND A
HUNDRED AND FORTY FOUR CARE BUT
LIKE. REALLY TINY NOW IF YOU IF
YOU WALK BY ANY INSTALLATION
WHERE WE'RE PUTTING FIBER WE'RE
PUTTING A THOUSAND HAIR FIBER.
CABLE YEAH THAT'S THE LARGER
THAN THE FIRST INTER
CONTINENTAL C. CABLE THAT
TRANSPORTED ALL THE DATA FROM
NORTH AMERICA ASIA RIGHT IT'S
HUGE AND REPORTING THAT AND
EVERYWHERE TO BACK UP ITS
NETWORK. BUT FOR FIVE G. WHAT
MAKES FIVE G. WIRELESS RADIO
FREQUENCY SPECTRUM SO I'M
BASING ARE THE EIGHT CURRENCIES
WE CALL IT AND SO I'LL GO
THROUGH THEM REALLY QUICKLY
YOU'VE ALREADY CUT. YOU KNOW
HEARD IT FROM THE PRIOR PANEL
BUT- THE THROUGHPUT OR THE
SPEEDS THAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
WITH FIVE G. SO THINK OF THE
FOUR GLT IS GIVING YOU MEGABIT
LEVEL CONNECTIVITY WHICH IS
PRETTY GOOD YOU COULD STREAM
NETFLIX RIGHT YOU CAN. DO
PRETTY MUCH ANYTHING ON YOUR
MOBILE DEVICE. FIVE G. IS GOING
TO GET. GIGABIT LEVEL
CONNECTIVITY AND SOME OF YOU
MAY SAY WELL I'M REALLY NEED TO
GET TO MY PHONE. AND YEAH
THAT'S THAT'S PROBABLY TRUE FOR
RIGHT NOW. BUT PEOPLE NEED A
GIG TO THEIR HOMES OR SMALL
BUSINESSES THAT'S AGAIN THE
KILLER APP FOR FIVE G. PEOPLE
THINK OF FIVE G. AS MOBILE
RIGHT. YES IT'S MOBILE BUT IT'S
ALSO GOING TO ENABLE FIXED
WIRELESS ACCESS INSTALLING A
NODE MUCH MUCH SMALLER THAN A
SATELLITE DISH LOOKS LIKE A
WIFI BOX ON YOUR ROOF. OR YOUR
WINDOW AND THAT ALLOWS THE FIVE
G. SIGNAL TO BE PROPAGATED ARE
BEAMED TO YOUR HOME OR SMALL
BUSINESS. THAT'S THE LAST MILE
AND TALKING ABOUT SO YOU GET
GIGABIT LEVEL SPEEDS. FIVE G.
HOME- OR FIVE G. SMALL
BUSINESS- THE PRIOR PANEL
TALKED ABOUT THE ENVIRONMENTAL-
IT- THE GOOD ENVIRONMENTAL
IMPACTS SO THE SERVICE
DEPLOYMENT IS THE SECOND
CAPABILITY. OF FIVE G. IT'S
ALSO CALLED NETWORK
VIRTUALISATION. SO THINK OF IT
IS INSTEAD OF IF SOMETHING
HAPPENS IN THIS FAST RADIO
ACCESS NETWORK THAT WE HAVE TO
BUILD THE TO CONNECT EVERYBODY.
SOMETHING HAPPENS WAY OUT IN
THE MIDDLE OF SOMEWHERE IN
CALIFORNIA. IT WOULD TAKE
SOMETIMES MONTHS FOR THE
ENGINEERING TEAM TO GO OUT. AND
FIND A HARDWARE THAT IS CAUSING
THAT PROBLEM. WITH FIVE G.
SERVICE DEPLOYMENT AND NETWORK
VIRTUALISATION BACK IT HAPPENED
BY THE SOFTWARE CAN HAPPEN
ELECTRONICALLY. SO WHAT WOULD
IT TAKE MONTHS. WOULD NOW TAKE
DAYS OR EVEN HOURS TO FIX THE
PROBLEM IN THE NETWORK
SOMEWHERE SO YOU HAVE THAT
AMAZING SERVICE DEPLOYMENT
CAPABILITY. THE THIRD CURRENCY
IS MOBILITY RIGHT SO WE EXPECT
YOU KNOW TALK ABOUT FIXED
WIRELESS ACCESS FIVE G. HOME
BEING THE KILLER APP- MOBILITY-
IS ALSO REALLY IMPORTANT FOR
OUR- SAFETY AND ACCESS TO NINE
ONE ONE. WHEN YOU'RE GOING
ANYWHERE IN CALIFORNIA USED TO
GO TO TAHOE LIKE IT'S GOT ZERO
BARS NOW WE GO TO TAHOE AND I
GET FOUR BARS IF YOU'RE HIKING
YOU WANT TO BE ABLE TO CALL
NINE ONE ONE. MOBILITY FIVE G.
IS GOING TO ENHANCE THE SPEEDS
THE COVERAGE IN THE CAPACITY OF
THE MOBILE NETWORK. AND IT'S
DESIGNED TO WORK AT FIVE
HUNDRED KILLER KILOMETERS PER
HOUR OR THREE HUNDRED TEN MILES
PER HOUR SO THINK OF. HIGH
SPEED TRAINS GOING TO BE ABLE
TO ACCESS FIVE G. I VERY HIS
YOURSELF. GOING AT HIGH VERY
HIGH SPEEDS THIS CURRENT IS
DATA BAR OR THE CUT I TALKED
ABOUT THE LAW ON A RIGHT SO YOU
HAVE COVERAGE DO I HAVE
COVERAGE IN THIS AREA RIGHT YES
I'M IN DOWNTOWN SAN FRANCISCO
RIGHT NOW YES I HAVE COVERAGE.
BUT IF EVERYONE GETS ON THE
NETWORK AT THE SAME TIME THAT
DOES THE BECOME A COVERAGE
PROBLEM APPLICANTS THE CAPACITY
PROBLEM. IS BY GETTING IN AN
ELEVATOR THERE'S ONLY SO MANY
PEOPLE THAT CAN GET IT. SO WITH
WITH FIVE G. THE CAPACITY OF
THE DATA VOLUME IS TEN
TERABYTES PER. SECOND PER
SQUARE KILOMETER THAT'S HUGE IF
YOU THINK OF THE PRIOR PANEL
TALKING ABOUT EVERY PAYING WITH
A CHIP IN IT. BEING CONNECTED
TO THE INTERNET GOING FORWARD.
MASSIVE AMOUNTS OF THE VOLUMES
BEING CONNECTED TO THE TO THE
INTERNET AS WE GO FORWARD WE
HAVE TO INCREASE THE CAPACITY
OF THESE NETWORKS. AND THIS
RESPECTABLE OUT THAT THAT
HAPPENED. THE SEVENTH. AND
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT CAPABILITY
OUR CURRENCY OF FIVE G. IS THE
ULTRA LOW LATENCY. LATENCY
ESPECIALLY IF YOU'RE A GAMER OR
IF YOUR KIDS ARE GAMERS. YOU
MIGHT HEAR THEM GLITCHED OUT OR
THEY PUSH THE BUTTON TO FIRE
AND THEN A SECOND LATER IT
FIRES ARE YOU HAVE A OUR VR
GOGGLES ON. IF YOU DON'T HAVE
VERY VERY LOW LATENCY WHICH IS
THE TIME IT TAKES FOR YOUR
DEVICE TO YOU PUSH YOUR DEVICE
TO DO SOMETHING AND IT DOESN'T
IT NEEDS TO BE BLINK OF AN EYE
OR IF YOU HAVE THAT AS A OUR VR
GOGGLES ON YOU'RE GONNA GET
KNOWLEDGE BECAUSE IT'S GONNA BE
LIKE. WAY OUT OF WHACK SO THE
EXTREMELY LOW BLINK OF AN EYE
LATENCY IS THE CAPABILITY OF
FIVE G. AND THEN OF COURSE THE
EIGHT CURRENCY THAT WE HAVE. IS
ULTRA HIGH SERVICE RELIABILITY
AND WE TALKED YOU KNOW THE
PANEL TALKED ABOUT HOW IT
CREDIBLY IMPORTANT. NETWORK
RESILIENCY AND RELIABILITY IS
AS WE DEPEND ON THESE NETWORKS
FOR EVERYTHING TO LIVE TO WORK
TO ACCESS PUBLIC SAFETY.
TELEHEALTH AND DISTANCE
LEARNING. SO I HOPE THAT
PROVIDED A LITTLE BIT OF
CONTEXT FOR UP TO FIVE G. THE
KILLER APP IS BROADBAND. AND
THE WORK CHAIRMAN THAT YEAR IN
THE LEGISLATURE THE GOVERNOR
DID. TO DELIVER THE SIX BILLION
DOLLAR BROADBAND PACKAGE IS.
GOING TO BE TRANSFORMATIONAL.
IF WE CAN ALSO MAKE SURE THAT
WE WORK WITH OUR CITIES AND
COUNTIES AND LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
TO GET THOSE PERMITS THROUGH.
IT THE AGREEMENTS IN PLACE. WE
DON'T WANT THAT MONEY TO BE
WASTED TO GET SHOVELS IN THE
GROUND WE ALSO NEED LOCAL WERE
FOR. THANK YOU VERY MUCH A
MYSTERY AS FOR YOUR
PRESENTATION- YES MANY OF US
HERE ARE FAMILIAR WITH THE LAST
MILE. OF PROBLEMS AND I'M GLAD
TO HEAR THAT FIVE G. COULD BE
IT OR IS THE SOLUTION TO FIXING
THAT PROBLEM. I WITH THAT- LET
US GO TO OUR LAST PANELIST AND-
FOR THIS PANEL. DO WHICH IS UP
MR CHRIS BOYER WHO IS THE VICE
PRESIDENT OF GLOBAL SECURITY
AND TECHNOLOGY POLICY. WITH A
TNT SO MISTER BOYER. FLOORS
YOURS. YES SOME OF THE NUMBER
OF THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
HAVING ME HERE TODAY- I'M CHRIS
WHERE WITH EIGHTEEN T. AND- MY
EXPERTISE IS REALLY ON THE
SECURITY SIDE OF FIVE USE
SOMEONE TO TALK ABOUT THAT BUT
SINCE. OUR PANEL IS ALSO
FOCUSED A LITTLE BIT ON A
DIFFERENT USE CASES AND- AROUND
FIVE YEAH I THOUGHT I WOULD
JUST START OUT START OFF BY
TALKING A LITTLE BIT ABOUT SOME
OF THE USE CASES WE'VE BEEN
DISCUSSING. HERE IN WASHINGTON
WITH VARIOUS ASPECTS F THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT SO- I THINK
SOME OF THE PREVIOUS SPEAKERS-
DR- NOT A COUPLE AND OTHERS-
AND RUDY ALSO SPOKE ABOUT THIS
ISSUE BUT THE REAL BENEFITS OF
FIVE G. R. THE LOWER LATENCY
THE MASSIVE CONNECTIVITY IN THE
FASTER SPEEDS ALL THREE OF
THOSE THINGS COMBINED. ARE WHAT
REALLY MAKE UP THE USE CASES
AND THE BENEFITS ARE GOING TO
SEE WITH FIVE G. IT'S A DEPEND
UPON- THE USE CASE DIFFERENT
ASPECTS OF THAT ARE MORE
IMPORTANT THAN OTHERS. BUT I
THINK I THINK THE MAIN POINT
HERE IS THAT FIVE G. IS REALLY
NOT ABOUT- JUST A CONSUMER
GETTING YOU KNOW FASTER ACCESS
TO THEIR FAVORITE VIDEO
STREAMING SERVICE RIGHT THERE
FOUND IT'S REALLY ABOUT. A LOT
OF THESE APPLICATIONS THAT CAN
BE ENABLED BY THAT COMBINATION
OF SPEAKING ACTIVITY AND- AND
LATENCY- AND SO YOU WHEN YOU
WHEN YOU LOOK BACK AT FOUR G. I
DON'T THINK ANYONE REALLY- A
MAGIC IN THAT. THE KILLER APP
FOR FOUR G. WOULD BE THINGS
LIKE THE GIG ECONOMY OR UBER
BUT THOSE ARE THE TYPES OF
APPLICATIONS THAT WE REALLY SAW
TAKE ADVANTAGE. OF THE FASTER
SPEED BEFORE CHEATING AND SO
WITH FIVE G. WE HAVE AN IDEA OF
WHAT A LOT OF THESE-
APPLICATIONS MIGHT BE
ESPECIALLY IN THE ENTERPRISE
SPACE BUT I THINK ON THE
CONSUMER SIDE. YOU KNOW THE-
FIVE G. WILL DO IS IT'LL
JUMPSTART. A WAVE OF THE
UNFORESEEN INNOVATION THAT IT'S
REALLY HARD TO PREDICT RIGHT
NOW BUT I THINK I THINK THERE
ARE SOME THINGS THAT ARE
HAPPENING TODAY- SOME COUPLE
GOOD EXAMPLES OF THIS ARE. YOU
AT AND T. WE OPENED UP A FIVE
G. INNOVATION STUDIO- APRIL
TWENTY TWENTY ONE- BUT THAT'S
REALLY INTENDED TO DO IS
XCELERATED PATH. TO MARKET FOR
NEW PRODUCT OFFERINGS IN IN
OTHER IT IS I JUST A COUPLE OF
THE OF USE CASE THAT WORK
LOOKING AT AND AT RIDICULOUS
INTERVENTIONS ONE IS IDEA OF A
DRONE CAN SO WE'VE BEEN WORKING
WITH MICROSOFT AS YOUR- YOU'RE
NOT FAMILIAR THAT MEASURE IT'S
THE MICROSOFT CLOUD PLATFORM-
IN THE DRONE COMPANY EVA- TO
EVALUATE HOW OUR FIVE G.
NETWORK COMBINED WITH EDGE
COMPUTING. CAN ALLOW FOR NEAR
TIME DRONE CONTROL EVEN EVEN
BEYOND VISUAL LINE OF SIGHT TO
COULD YOU TAKE ADVANTAGE OF THE
FIVE G. NETWORK TO CONTROL
DRONES. BEYOND THE VISUAL LINE
OF SIGHT IN THIS IS
PARTICULARLY INTERESTING
EIGHTEEN T. BECAUSE- WE HAVE A
LOT OF PUBLIC SAFETY CUSTOMERS
WE HAVE TO USE DRONES AND- THE
PAST RECOVERY SITUATIONS AND
MONITORING THE NETWORK SO- I
UNDERSTAND HOW IT USED THE FIVE
G. NETWORK TO CONTROL DRONES IS
AN ISSUE THAT- IS IT IS THE USE
CASE THAT WERE PARTICULARLY
INTERESTED IN- ANOTHER EXAMPLE
IS HOLOGRAPHIC COMMUNICATIONS-
THIS IS REALLY A CONSUMER
APPLICATION BUT- YOU KNOW IN
DECEMBER. EIGHTEENTH IN
ERICSSON WE WORK TOGETHER ON.
THE RAINY. ET HEARSE OF
HOLOGRAPHIC COMMUNICATION
WITHOUT THE TYPE OF HARDWARE
THE TECHNOLOGY TYPICALLY
REQUIRES SO WE CAN USE. THE
COMBINATION OF FIVE G. A. I. IN
SOME OF THE- MOBILE AND
COMPUTING FUNCTIONALITY- THE
DOCTOR NEED TO CALL TALK SPOKE
ABOUT. YOU KNOW WITH THE-
STANDARD FIVE G. SMARTPHONE TO
DELIVER. YOU KNOW HOLOGRAPHIC
COMMUNICATION ARE HOLOGRAPHIC
IMAGES SO THAT'S- THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT WE'RE JUST
TESTING IS VERY MUCH IN THE-
INITIAL STAGES BUT WE DO THINK
THAT SOMETHING IT WILL BE
POSSIBLE FOR. A MASS CONSUMER
ADOPTION SOMEWHERE DOWN THE
ROAD- ALSO WORKING ON SMART
MANUFACTURING AND SO- YOU KNOW
WE CAN DO THINGS- IN TERMS OF
MANUFACTURING THAT REALLY
TRANSFORMS THAT- YOU KNOW WE
KEEP WE CAN COMBINE. YOU KNOW
FIVE G. WITH EDGE COMPUTING
FUNCTIONALITY- TO PROVIDE SMART
SAFETY DEVICES FOR
MANUFACTURERS ACTUALLY. WE
ACTUALLY HAVE A- A SMART FIVE
G. A MANUFACTURING FACILITY
THAT WE PUT TOGETHER IN AUSTIN
WITH WITH- WITH SAM SONG IT'S A
GREAT. DEMONSTRATION OF FIVE G.
MANUFACTORY I SEEN DIED THAT
ILLUSTRATE HOW CAN LIVE BECAUSE
YOU COULD PUSH THE COMPUTE
FUNCTION FIVE G. WITH ALL THAT
YOU KNOW CLOSER TO THE YOU CAN
ACTUALLY UP WITH THAT WHERE FOR
EXAMPLE THE CRITICAL DATA THAT
USED TO RUNA MANUFACTURING
PLANT OUR MANUFACTURING
FACILITY. IS SELF CONTAINED ON
THE PREMISE YOU CAN PUT THE
COMPUTE FUNCTIONALITY ON TREND.
IN THE CALL YOU KNOW IN A CALL
IN A AN ON PREM SERVER CLOUD
ENVIRONMENT WE AN KEEP THAT
DATA. CONFINED TO THE TO THE
MANUFACTURING FACILITY AND ONLY
ALLOW YOU KNOW THE
COMMUNICATIONS THAT ARE
NECESSARY LIKE LET'S SAY AN
EMPLOYEE WANTS TO GO CHECK
THEIR EMAIL OR SOMETHING. AND
THEY HAVE TO GO ON THE PUBLIC
INTERNET THAT YOU CAN REALLY
START TO. DO THINGS TOO- DIVIDE
UP TRAFFIC AND ENSURE THAT
SEEKS THAT REALLY- IMPORTANT
TRAFFIC NEVER LEAVES THE-
MANUFACTURING LOCATION BY
LEVERAGING A COMBINATION OF
FIVE G. AND OTHER. TECHNOLOGIES
SO THERE'S A LOT OF THINGS
HAPPENING HERE- THAT WE THINK
WILL BE- YOU KNOW REALLY CHANGE
HOW MANUFACTURING WORKS- IS
IMMENSE AND SOME OF THE OTHER
BENEFITS THAT WE'RE CURRENTLY
WORKING ON. IN ON THE CONSUMER
SIDE YOU KNOW I MENTIONED HOW
THE GRAPHICS BUT THERE'S ALSO
OTHER APPLICATIONS. YOU KNOW
GAMINI E. SPORTS TRAVEL
APPLICATIONS ALL SORTS OF
THINGS THAT ARE OUT THERE I
THINK THE BOTTOM LINE IS THAT
YOU WILL KNOW WHEN WE SEE IT
RIGHT A LOT OF THIS IS GONNA
HAPPEN. OVER TIME- NETWORKS
GOING TO BE BUILT OUT AND I
THINK WHAT WE'LL SEE IS A LOT
OF THE INNOVATORS FRANKLY- YOU
KNOW I SPENT THREE YEARS IN.
SILICON VALLEY WORKING FOR
EIGHTEEN T. AND- YOU KNOW I
THINK A LOT OF THE INNOVATORS
THEY'RE THE ONES WHO WILL
ULTIMATELY. BE WORKING ON
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT WHAT THEY
CAN DO ON TOP OF. THE BENEFITS
THAT RECEIVE A FIVE G. TERMS OF
BROADBAND. AND LATENCY- THAT'S
KIND OF JUST WILL RESPECT ON
YOU TO BE OUR YES HERE TO SEE
SO THIS IS SOMETHING THAT'S
BEEN ENTIRE LIFE BASED WORKING
ON SECURING ISSUES FIVE G.
NETWORKS- YOU KNOW SOMEONE
WHO'S BEEN A LOT OF QUESTIONS
ABOUT FIVE G. SECURITY. YEAH
WHEN I THINK ABOUT SECURITY IS
NOT JUST THE NETWORK RIGHT NOW
I THINK- SOME OF THE PREVIOUS
SPEAKERS TOUCHED ON THIS.
SECURITY IS REALLY ABOUT EACH
ONE OF THE COMPONENTS OF THE
NETWORK RIGHTS SO. THE NETWORK
IS NOT JUST LIKE THE PART THAT
WE MADE CHANGES EIGHTEEN T. BUT
IT INCLUDES THE DEVICES. IT
INCLUDES THE APPLICATION LAYER
THAT'S IN THE CLOUD. SO YOU
REALLY HAVE TO SECURE ALL OF
THAT- BUT AT. THE BOTTOM LINE
FOR FIVE G. IS THAT IT WILL BE.
THE MOST ADVANCED OUR MOST
SECURE NETWORK. OUR GENERATION
OF WIRELESS THAT WE'VE DEPLOYED
TODAY- AND THAT'S PREDOMINANTLY
BECAUSE FIVE G. IS BEING
DESIGNED WITH SECURITY IN MIND.
YOU KNOW WHAT WE DID A LOT OF
THINGS THAT HAPPEN IN THE PAST
INSECURITIES BEEN WORKABLE
TIME- BUT I THINK STARTING WITH
WITH FOUR G. LTE NOW
SPECIFICALLY WITH FIVE G.
THERE'S A LOT OF FOCUS ON FIRE
ON SECURITY- YOU KNOW. IN THE
ECOSYSTEM IN THE STANDARDS
BODIES THEMSELVES SO. A GOOD
EXAMPLE OF THIS IS THAT. FIVE
G. SECURITY IS BEING ADDRESSED
AT THREE GP THREE GPP IS THE-
IS THE STANDARDS BODY THAT'S
OFFICIALLY DEVELOPING THE
STANDARDS FOR FIVE G. THEY HAVE
A DEDICATED WORKING GROUP FOR
FIVE G. SECURITY. CALLED THREE
GPP AS A THREE. SB WHAT IT'S
DOING ITS TACKLE YOU KNOW
KI<c.cyan> FOR. IN THE STANDARD AND</c>
LESSONS FROM SO THE BEST THING
ABOUT THIS PROCESS IS VERY.
URGENT SO WHEN SECURITY ISSUES
ARE IDENTIFIED YOU CAN TAKE IN
THREE GPP. STANDARDS BODY WILL
WORK ON. A NEW STANDARDS IN
DIFFERENT- SOLUTIONS THAT CAN
BE PUT IN PLACE TO- TO IMPROVE
FIVE G. SECURITY. AND THEN THEY
CAN UPDATE THE STANDARD SO
EFFECTIVELY. YOU HAVE YOU KNOW
FIVE G. SECURITY. BUILT INTO
THIS INTO THE FIVE G. WIRELESS
STANDARDS THEMSELVES- SO THAT'S
THAT'S A GREAT STEP FORWARD FOR
THE INDUSTRY AND WE THINK THAT
THAT LEADS TO. A SUBSTANTIAL
SECURITY BENEFITS OVER TIME.
THERE'S ALSO A LOT OF-
ARCHITECTURAL DIFFERENCES
BETWEEN FIVE G. AND FOUR G.
THAT IMPACT THE NETWORK IT WILL
GIVE US NEW SECURITY
CAPABILITIES- SO I THINK- I
THINK ON SOME OF THE PREVIOUS
SPEAKERS TOUCHED ON THIS BUT-
YOU KNOW FIVE G. REALLY
INTRODUCES THE NEW NETWORK
SEGMENT THE MOBILE ADS. THAT
WILL ENABLE YOU NEXT GENERATION
I MISS IS ALSO LEASING HAVING
WITH APPLICATIONS BUT- THE
NETWORK GETS REALLY INCLUDES
SOME OF THE COMPUTE
FUNCTIONALITY. THAT WAS
TRADITIONALLY PART OF THE CORE
PARTS OF THE NETWORK YOU CAN
THINK OF A TRADITIONAL WIRELESS
NETWORK YOU HAD. YOU HAVE THE
DEVICE THAT CONNECTS TO A CELL
TOWER. TO CELL TOWER HAS FIBER
BACKHAUL THAT GOES TO- YOU KNOW
A CENTRALIZED LOCATION WHERE
THE CORE NETWORK RESIDES. NOT
IN THAT COURT NUMBER CONNECTS
TO THE INTERNET. YOU KNOW IN
THE IN THE PAST A LOT OF THE
APPLICATIONS THAT WERE. THAT
WERE RIGHT ON YOUR MOBILE
DEVICE. WE'RE ALL COMING OFF
THE INTERNET YOU CONNECTED TO
THE CORE. IT'S SO THE COMPUTE
FUNCTIONALITY ALL RESIDED IN
THE CORE OR EVEN ON THE
INTERNET ITSELF ON THE PUBLIC
INTERNET SO YOU HAVE TO GO
THROUGH THE ENTIRE NETWORK. YOU
KNOW BEFORE YOU COULD ACTUALLY
GET TO. WHERE THE APPLICATION
IS BEING RUN- YOU KNOW WITH
MOBILE EDGE COMPUTING YOU NOW
ARE RUNNING THOSE APPLICATIONS
CLOSER CLOSER TO THE EDGE. SO
BY SHORTEN THAT DISTANCE THE
AMOUNT OF. THE AMOUNT OF- THERE
THE DISTANCE THAT THE- DEVICE
HAS TO TRAVEL TO GET TO THE
COMPUTER. KNOWLEDGE THAT'S
WHAT'S GOOD THAT'S WHAT GIVES
YOU. THE LOWER LATENCY BENEFITS.
THAT YOU SEE WITH FIVE G. BUT
THERE'S OTHER BENEFITS THAT IS
WHY AS THE BEST NAKED FUNCTION
CLOSER THE EDGE WE CAN NOW DO
YOU THAT WE SHOULD BE DID IN
THE OF THE NET FIRST WE CAN NO
THOSE FUNCTION HAS SOFTWARE IN
THE EDGE OF THE NETWORK SO. FOR
EXAMPLE WE DO A LOT OF-
DISTRIBUTED DENIAL OF SERVICE
ATTACK DETECTION- WE CAN LOOK
FOR THINGS LIKE EXFILTRATION
EVENTS OF DATA- THOSE ARE THE
TYPES OF THINGS THAT WE MONITOR
THE NETWORK FOR. JUDICIAL
RECORD THE NETWORKS OF MORE
FURTHER BACK IN THE NETWORK NOW
WE CAN SHIFT A LOT OF THAT
CAPABILITY. CLOSER TO THE EDGE.
WORKS WE CAN ACTUALLY SEE SOME
OF THE ATTACKS HAPPENING. YOU
KNOW CLOSER TO THE USER WHICH
ALLOWS US TO- YOU KNOW PINPOINT
EARN ARE NARROWED DOWN THE
SCOPE OF THESE ATTACKS. AND
REALLY TRY TO ADDRESS THEM
CLOSER TO THOSE USERS BEFORE
THEY GET BACK INTO THE BROADER
PARTS OF THE NETWORK. OR WE CAN
MINIMIZE THE AMOUNT OF DATA.
THAT'S BEING DISRUPTED THERE
BECAUSE IT'S ONLY AFFECTING A
SMALL SET OF USERS RECEIVE
GETTING BACK INTO THE CORE PART
OF THE NETWORK. WHERE IT REALLY
AFFECTS OF A MUCH BROADER BASE
OF THE TRAFFIC- SO THAT SO I
THINK THAT FUNDAMENTAL CHANGE
IN ARCHITECTURE BY MOVING THAT.
THAT FUNCTIONALITY CLOSER TO
THE USER TO THE ADS. ACTUALLY
GIVES US- QUITE A BIT MORE
FLEXIBILITY TO BUILDING
SECURITY. INTO THE NETWORK
ITSELF- THERE'S ALSO SOME
ENHANCEMENTS TO SECURITY AND
FIVE G. I CAN IMAGINE A LOT OF
THIS IS COMING THROUGH THE
STANDARDS. SO ONE OF THEM IS.
IT IS ARE ALL NETWORK IF YOU
CAN STOP JUST TO BE CLEAR
THERE'S OTHER THINGS GOING ON
WITH DEVICES. AND APPLICATIONS
BUT NOT REPEAT ITSELF LIKE
EIGHTEEN TO HEAR OTHERS
MANAGED. OTHER SOME VERY
SPECIFIC THINGS ARE HAPPENING
SO- THE THREE GPP. STANDARDS
CALL FOR- STRONGER ENCRYPTION
OF THE OVER THE AIR INTERFACE-
THAT WILL ENHANCE SECURITY
BETWEEN. THE FIVE MOBILE DEVICE
TO THE NETWORK SO IN THE PAST-
A LOT OF THE DATA SENT BETWEEN
THE MOBILE DEVICE IN THE
NETWORK LIKE WHEN YOUR DEVICE
IS AUTHENTICATING. ON THE
NETWORK AND TRANSMITTING DATA
BETWEEN YOUR PHONE. AND THE
TOWER- YOU KNOW A LOT OF THAT
DATA WAS SENT IN THE CLEAR-
THIS WILL NOT BE ENCRYPTED- SO
WHAT'S CALLED THE IN THE-
INFORMATION ON THE WIRELESS
NETWORK WITHOUT. BEING
CORRECTED SO. THAT OVER THE
INTERFACING WITH THE FIVE G.
STANDARD THAT FIVE G.
INTRODUCES THE NEWS ADDS ARE
PROTECTION CALLED AS PPO
SEVERAL THAT PROTECTS ROLE MEAN
FOR. SO THAT THAT RELIEF THE
ACTUALLY BETWEEN THE BY WHEN
THEY WERE ACROSS AND THAT WILL
ALLOW US TO IN THIS NEW
PROTECTION PROXY WILL ALLOW US
TO INTRODUCE- NEW BETTER
MITIGATIONS AGAINST WHAT ARE
CALLED SIGNALLY ATTACKS OF
THINGS LIKE SS SEVEN AND
DIAMETER TAX. SO IS HIS WHERE
IS A ROAMING BETWEEN CARRIERS
NETWORKS- FIVE G. ALSO
INTRODUCES A SUBSCRIBER
IDENTITY PRIVACY- YOU SEE THE
SUBSCRIPTION- CONCEALED
IDENTIFIER WHICH REALLY
DESIGNED- TO CONCEAL AND
PROTECT A FIVE YEAR
SUBSCRIPTION AND IN A FIRE
WHICH COULD HELP MITIGATE THE
VULNERABILITY IN THE CATCHER SO
I DON'T A LOT OF TECHNICAL.
PROBABLY GET BUT IF YOU THINK
BUT WE DIDN'T THE CATCHER IS
BASICALLY A SCENARIO WHERE- YOU
THINK OF LIKE I'VE EVER HEARD
OF A BICYCLE THE STING RAY
WHERE SOMEONE CAN COME IN AND
KIND OF- SPOOF THE NETWORK AND
TRY TO GET YOU TO CONNECT TO
THE STINGRAY DEVICE SO THEY CAN
ACTUALLY SEE YOUR DATA- BY BY
CONCEALING THOSE IDENTIFIERS IN
THE COMBINATION OF SOME OF THE-
OVER THEIR INTERFACE YOU COULD
IMAGINE. PREVIOUSLY WE CAN
EFFECTIVELY FOR WORKS- THE USES
OF SOME OF THOSE TYPES OF
DEVICES. IN THE COUNTRY'S GOING
FORWARD WHICH IS A BIG ISSUE WE
FOLLOW- MOBILE SECURITY-
WITHOUT ABILITY- THERE'S ALSO
INCREASED HOME NETWORK CONTROL-
FOR AUTHENTICATION ON THE FIVE
G. NETWORKS AND VERIFYING THAT
DEVICE IS PRESENT THE REQUESTED
SERVICE FROM THE NETWORK- AND
THEN THERE'S A ADDITIONAL
FRAMEWORK IS BEING PUT IN PLACE
TO FACILITATE THE USE OF.
SIMILAR AUTHENTICATION METHODS
FOR THREE D. P. P. AND NON
THREE GPP THAT WORKS SO LIKE
THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN CELLULAR
AND WIFI AS THE DEVICE JUST
ACROSS DIFFERENT A DIFFERENT
TYPES O WIRELESS NETWORKS SO
THERE'S A LOT OF DIFFERENT
THINGS WAS GOING ON IN FIVE D.
REALLY AROUND AUTHENTICATION
ENCRYPTION- AND- AND HOW THE
DEVICE CONNECTS TO THE NETWORK
AND TRANSMITS DATA. ALL OF
THESE THINGS SHOULD BE- SHOULD
REALLY HELP MANAGE THE SECURITY
ISSUES AROUND FIVE G. AND THEN
WHEN YOU COMBINE THOSE
ENHANCEMENTS WITH THE MENTIONED
EARLIER WHICH THE IN THE A LOT
OF IT A LOT OF THE CORE
FUNCTIONALITY CLOSER TO THE
EDGE. AND THEN YOU LAYER ON TOP
OF THAT SOME OTHER TECHNOLOGIES
THAT WE THAT WE'RE NOW SEEING.
YOU KNOW REALLY FAST LIKE
MACHINE OUR AND ARTIFICIAL
INTELLIGENCE ANDCLOSELY BOTTOM
THOSE ALL COMBINE ONE ANOTHER
WILL CREATING SECURE AND IT
WILL BE SEATED IN NETWORK I'M
NOT GONNA SAY THAT'S A IS GONNA
BE PERFECT AND WE ALL KNOW IT'S
A INTEREST WERE COST MAKING TO
IMPROVE SECURITY- BUT WOULD YOU
THINK THAT THE FIVE G. NETWORK
ARCHITECTURE CHANGES THAT ARE
HAPPENING COMBINED WITH THESE
OTHER TECHNOLOGY ADVANCES. WILL
ULTIMATELY GIVE US GREATER
FLEXIBILITY AND BETTER
CAPABILITY. ULTIMATELY DEAL
WITH SECURITY THREATS AS WE SEE
THEM NO AS WE GO TO FIVE YOU
CAN BE ALL. SO THAT HAPPENED TO
QUESTIONS I YOU VERY MUCH FOR
YOUR PRESENTATION I DO HAVE A
COUPLE OF QUESTIONS TO FOLLOW
UP. WITH THE PANELISTS THE
FIRST QUESTION. ARE MOST
INDUSTRIES AT A PLACE WHERE
THEY FULLY UNDERSTAND THE
EXTENT TO WHICH A FIVE G.
NETWORKS CHANGES THEIR-
RESPECTIVE INDUSTRIES. OR IS
THERE STILL A GREAT DEAL OF
UNKNOWNS ANY ANY PALACE SO WE
FEEL LIKE THE CHINA. I CAN TELL
YOU A LITTLE BIT OF THE
PERSPECTIVE OF MANY. SMALL
BUSINESSES THAT BE TALKED TO-
AND I THINK OF ME AS A LARGE
COMPANIES TO UNDERSTAND THE
POTENTIAL OF FIVE G. MANY SMALL
COMPANIES ARE AT SIXTY EIGHT
AND HOLDING BACK ON I THINK
THEY ARE EAGER TO REALIZE THE
BENEFITSTHAT THEY HAD A LOT.
OF ARE THERE ARE CERTAIN THE
ALBERTA CRIMELINE THEN THEY
HAVE TO ENGAGE IN AND THEY HAVE
TO AND WHAT IT MEANS FOR THEM
INCOME STUFF- UTILIZING THOSE
FEATURES. ASSISTANCE ON THIS
BECAUSE OUR ORIGINAL CREATING
THE OPTION OR CUSTOMIZED REYES
SO THAT IS SOMETHING THAT NOT
EVEN FAMILY AGENCIES FOR
EXAMPLE A STRUGGLING THE GUY
TRYING TO UNDERSTAND THEN TO
ACTUALLY TAP INTO THOSE OPTIONS
SO I'LL I'LL DEFER TO MY
PARENTS. WHO COULD NOT BE MORE
THAN THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I
ANSWER I SAW LIKE A AVERAGE FOR
AND WAS BUT FOR IN HIS HEART
WITH THE AND WEB SERVICE TO DO
SOMETHING CALLED MOBILE EDGE
COMPUTE AND MOBILE EDGE COMPUTE
COMBINED WITH FIVE G. AND THE
MASSIVE FIBER- BACKHAUL AND
TRANSPORT IT IS NECESSARY. IT
THINK OF IT AS BUILDING MANY
CLOUDS CLOSE TO THE EDGE OF THE
NETWORK SO- AMAZON HAS ALREADY.
TRANSFORMED OUR LIVESBY
BUILDING THE CARPET YOU KNOW
HELPING BUILD A CLOUD ONE OF
THE CLOUD PROVIDERS. WHERE
CONTENT CAN BE STORED SO THAT
DOESN'T HAVE TO BE STORED ON
YOUR DEVICE. BUT IT HAS STATE
AT ALL THAT CONTENT HAS TO GET
OVER THE NETWORK SO IF YOU
COULD BUILD. MANY CLOUDS CLOSER
TO THE EDGE OF THE NETWORK.
BACK FURTHER WITH THE EIGHT
CURRENCIES A FIVE G. REALLY IT
CAN DELIVER- MASSIVE TAG
KRUGMAN'S FOR INDUSTRY AND I
JUST SAW A COMMERCIAL. I TALK
ABOUT ALL THE DIFFERENT WAYS
THAT. A W. S. AT MOBILE EDGE
COMPUTE. ARE ATTACKING PEOPLE'S
LIVES RIGHT NOW I MEAN THIS IS
FOR THE OTHERS THAT WOULD
RESULT THERE'S THEY BECOME
MISSOURI ABOUT AT COMPUTING
WHICH YOU WERE WERE PARTNERING
WITH MICROSOFT YOU WERE WHICH
IS A COMPETITOR TO AMAZON BUT
THERE KIND OF OFFERING VERY
SIMILAR FROM SO MOVING THAT
COMPUTE FUNCTIONALITY CLOSER TO
THE EDGE WHICH WILL ALLOW ALL
OF THE SERVICE PROVIDERS ALL
THE THREE NATIONAL CARRIERS
WILL BE ABLE TO INTRODUCE A LOT
OF THAT FUNCTIONALITY I THINK.
I THINK- AND WANTED TO COMPETE
WITH EACH OTHER FOR THAT
BUSINESS I THINK OVERALL I KIND
OF AGREE WITH- TECHNICAL FALL
HERE THAT YOU KNOW IT SEEMS TO
ME THAT WHAT WE'LL SEE IS A LOT
OF ENTERPRISE FIVE G. ROLLOUT
AND THEN ULTIMATELY AS THOSE
APPLICATIONS REDUCE THE
STRUCTURAL DOWN DOWN MARKETS
OTHER. OTHER SEGMENTS YOU KNOW
I THINK- YOU KNOW YOU SEE SOME
OF THESE USE CASES EMERGE AND
THEN USERS WILL WILL PICK UP ON
THIS TEAM SAID IN A LITTLE
START AFFECT OTHER. OTHER
ASPECTS OF THE BUSINESS BUT
SOME OF THESE THINGS ARE NOT
NECESSARILY JUST LIMITED
ENTERPRISES RIGHTS TO SOME OF
THE THINGS THAT MEASURE EARLIER
LIKE LIKE DRONES ARE USED IN A
LOT OF APPLICATIONS ARE NOT
JUST ENTERPRISE APPLICATIONS AS
OUR- SO THESE OTHER
TECHNOLOGIES SO IT'LL BE
INTERESTING TO SEE. ULTIMATELY
HOW THAT ROLLS OUT BUT I THINK
MOST BUSINESSES ARE SURELY THE
ENTERPRISE SPACE WE GET TONS OF
QUESTIONS ABOUT FIVE G. AS IN
MY- YES I WOULD SAY THAT
THEY'RE THEY'RE PRETTY AWARE OF
WHAT'S GOING ON THERE- YOU KNOW
WE'LL WE'LL SEE HOW IT PLAYS.
OUT IS THAT THESE THINGS REDUCE
I THANK YOU FOR. MUCH BELIEVE I
HEARD THE TERM SMART SIT BE
BEING MENTIONED BY ONE OF
PANELISTS THE QUESTION IS IN
THE CREATION OF SMART CITY
TECHNOLOGIES THAT ARE
DEVELOPED. TO MAKE
DETERMINATIONS ABOUT
INDIVIDUALS. HOW DOES. THE FIVE
G. TECHNOLOGY ADDRESS ISSUES
LIKE BIASES. ARE WHETHER IT IS
RACIAL BIAS. OR AGENDA BIAS OR
ANY KIND OF- BIASES. I THINK
THIS IS A PROBLEM OF PIZZA- I
AND DONALD I DO NOT NECESSARILY
HAVE ANYTHING TO DO THAT GIVE
IT TO US. I THINK THE FIGHT
DIDN'T HAVE ANYTHING THE
DETECTION PRACTICES. WELL I
NINETEEN BECAUSE. IT THESE
SCHOOLS THAT ARE PROVIDED AND I
THINK IN BEFORE OCTOBER
INTELLIGENCE MAY LEARNING I ARE
GOING TO BE FEATURED HEAVILY IN
TRYING TO DRIVE USE FROM THAT
THAT IS BEING RIGHT WHAT WE
HAVE TO BE SEVERAL OF HIS
OFFICE THE NUMBER BEAGLE OR THE
UNDER THE BE UNDER I RECORD AND
I AND THE EXTRA I POTENTIAL THE
MIGHT BE THAT NO ONE PLACE IDEA
THAT THIS IS RUNNING FIVE G. IS
A DOESN'T LOOK UP TO ME ALSO BY
CLOSE REELING ON AUG YEAH I AND
MACHINE LEARNING TO HELP
OPTIMIZE THE BILL'S GOING TO
THEY CAN BE BY THEMSELVES AND
SOME FRIENDS YOU COULD SAY I
DON'T SEE I THINK IN THESE
AREAS THAT SELECT ME BUT IS
MADE HAVE COME AND IS OF THE
HERE TO TALK DOES THE UNDER SO
COMMUNITY BY ABOUT NOT GONNA
PEOPLE THE QUOTE THAT WOULD BE
GREAT BECAUSE I JUST DON'T
NIGHT SO TO THAT CAN COME UP
YES THEREFORE I THE KIND OF
BIASES THAT NEED BE PRESENT IN
DATA THAT THE C. IF FOREST
TRAINING THEM OUR RECORDS BUT I
BUT RECOGNITION IS THE FOR PART
AMERICAN ON THE HUMANS OF THIS
TO. THE SITE INTO MUST BE
DISMISSED AND MAKES THE DENTIST
THAT LICENSE MAY LIST AND LEARN
TO LOOK FOR THEM BEFORE THAT I
RELEASED FROM THE TRAINING
OTHER THAN SOME OF THE DATA I
THINK YOU WILL BE IN A MUCH
PLACE. I THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
OKAY GREAT I WOULD JUST I WOULD
IS THAT THE YOU KNOW THERE I
DON'T THINK IT'S A UNIQUE FIVE
G. BUT I THE IDEA OF A AYE AM
IN THE YOU OBVIOUSLY RAISES THE
OF AND THERE'S BEEN A THERE'S
BEEN ONGOING DISCUSSION ABOUT
WHAT I'LL CALL THE ETHICAL YOU
OF AI IN THIS TIMES TO CHECK
SOMETHING I KNOW EIGHTEEN WE
HAVE A DON'T I DON'T KNOW THIS
FOR BUT THERE'S ANOTHER GROUP
THE COMPANY HAS BEEN LOOKING AT
THIS ARTIFICE TO MAKE SURE THAT
YOU KNOW AS WE THOSE OF FROM
THE FISHING SEASON THE NETWORK
AND I MENTIONED EARLIER YOU
KNOW ONE OF THE USE CASES FOR
AI AND ML IT IS SECURITY- IN
THOSE TYPES OF THINGS THAT IT
DOCUMENTS SECURE UNETHICAL
MANNER SO. I THINK THAT'S A
VERY INTERESTING TOPIC THERE'S
BEEN A LOT OF DISCUSSION HERE
IN DC ABOUT EXACTLY HOW HOW TO
DO THAT I KNOW IT'S AN ONGOING
CONCERN A LOT OF IT IS NOT
UNIQUE TO FIVE G. IT'S KIND OF
A COMPASS IS ALL OF THE USE OF
A. I. AND ALL WHICH REALLY IS.
YOU KNOW SPANS FIVE G. BUT ALSO
CLOUD NETWORKS AND APPLICATIONS
ETCETERA SO- IT'S AN ONGOING
DISCUSSION AND I THINK
SOMETHING THAT THAT'S WHAT
THAT'S GOING TO BE. REALLY A
KEY CONCERN. FOR ALL THE
COMPANIES INVOLVED HERE GOING
FORWARD THANK CHRISTMAS
CHAIRMAN I ADD IT FROM FROM A
DEPLOYMENT ASPECT- YOU KNOW I
TALKED ABOUT- FIVE G.
TECHNOLOGY BEING POISED TO.
SOLVE THE LAST MILE PROBLEM IN
LARGE PART. NOW YOU KNOW. ALL
THERE ARE GOING TO BE POCKETS.
OF OUR STATE. THAT ARE SO
REMOTE AND SO CHALLENGING. THAT
A HUNDRED PERCENT- BUILD OUT-
IS NOT GOING TO BE- POSSIBLE
BUT- IN LARGE PART. UBIQUITOUS
DEPLOYMENT. IS THE GOAL. AND IS
THE INTENTION OF THESE.
NETWORKS UTILIZING BOTH. THE
HIGH BAND AND- THE MID BAND
SPECTRUM IN COMBINATION WITH.
THE MASSIVE FIBER- BACK CALLS
I. AND TRANSPORT I WOULD SAY
THAT. THESE DEVICES THAT WE
HAVE RIGHT THEY ARE AGNOSTIC TO
THE USER RIGHT THE NETWORK.
WHEN YOU'RE GOING AROUND JUST
TO SEE IS THAT THERE IS A
DEVICE REQUESTING ACCESS TO IT.
AND SO WHAT ARE ENGINEERS DO IN
BUILDING OUT THE RADIO ACCESS
NETWORK IS THEY BUILD WHERE
WIRELESS GOES WHERE THE PEOPLE
GO RIGHT. YOU HAVE TO BUILD
BASED ON THE DENSITY OF OF
USAGE. AND I THINK THAT AS WE
BUILD OUT THESE NETWORKS I
WOULDUNDERSCORE THE URGENCY OF
YOUR QUESTION TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE ADDRESS ISSUES TO MAKE SURE
THAT- WE'RE BUILDING OUT NOT
ONLY IN TERMS OF LOWER INCOME
AND SOCIO ECONOMICALLY-
DEPRESSED COMMUNITIES BUT ALSO
IN TERMS OF RACIAL EQUITY THERE
IS A COMPONENT IF YOU LOOK AT.
THE DATA YOU CAN'T JUST LOOK AT
WHERE THE LOW INCOME- PEOPLE
ARE YOU ALSO HAVE TO LOOK FOR
MY CRITICAL RACE A PERSPECTIVE.
WHERE ARE VULNERABLE
POPULATIONS ARE AND MAKE SURE
THAT THESE NETWORKS DO GET
DEPLOYED UBIQUITOUSLY BUT THE
DEVICES THEMSELVES ARE TOTALLY
AGNOSTIC TO WHO THE USER IS
IT'S JUST DEVICE TRYING TO
CONNECT TO THE NETWORK GOT IT I
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. FOR YOUR
PRESENTATION SO I THINK THOSE
ARE THE ONLY QUESTIONS OUT THAT
I HAVE AT THIS POINT- SO THAT
BRINGS US TO THE NEXT PANEL. OF
THE TOPIC OF THAT IS BUILDING
AND IMPLEMENTING FIVE G.
NETWORKS- ADJOINING THE PANEL
OR THREE OUR SPEAKERS SO WE
START WITH US MISIA PARKER WHO
IS THE DIRECTOR OF NETWORK
ENGINEERING AND OPERATIONS WITH
T. MOBILE- JEFF NEAL
LEGISLATIVE REPRESENTATIVE
WHICH CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES. AND
ROBERT TRIP MADE A THIRD
MANAGING PARTNER OF TELECOM LAW
FIRM PC SO WITH THAT- MISS
PARKER. HOW WOULD YOU PLEASE
SELECT THE START YEAH THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR HAVING ME TODAY AND
TO SPEAK TO YOU ABOUT THE
NETWORK- FROM THE CARRICK'S
PERSPECTIVE OBVIOUSLY I'M TO
COME FROM THE KERRIER
PERSPECTIVE- AS MANY OF YOU
MIGHT BE WELL VERSED. ABOUT
NEXT NETWORK INFRASTRUCTURE-
FOR WIRELESS FACILITIES IN
GENERAL I JUST WANT TO TOUCH
UPON- KIND OF HOW WE'RE GOING
TO IMPLEMENT FIVE G. ANY
UPGRADES THAT ARE NEEDED TO THE
NETWORK- SO OUR WIRELESS
FACILITIES CONSISTING OF BASE
STATIONS ANTENNAS RADIO OUR AND
BACK ALL ALONG WITH OTHER
EQUIPMENT AND- THE WAY THAT WE
LOOK AT THE DEPLOYMENT OF FIVE
G. INFRASTRUCTURE TO THE
ALREADY EXISTING INFRASTRUCTURE
THAT WE HAVE. IS AS TECHNOLOGY
ADVANCES WE OBVIOUSLY HAVE TO
UPGRADE- THE FACILITIES THAT WE
CURRENTLY HAVE AND IN SOME
CASES IN LOCATIONS WHERE WE DO
NOT HAVE FACILITIES WE WOULD
HAVE TO DETERMINE WHETHER OR
NOT WE WOULD NEED TO- PLACE THE
NEW FACILITY BUT FOR THE MOST
PART. WHEN IT COMES TO THE FIVE
G. UPGRADES A MANY OF THE
CARRIERS ARE LOOKING TO UPGRADE
EXISTING FACILITIES- AND THAT
WOULD CONSIST OF- ANTENNA ADS.
RADIO ADS AND B. STATION-
UPGRADES- ALONG WITH SOMETHING
THAT I THOUGHT WAS REALLY GOOD
THAT RUDY ADDED IN THE LAST
PANEL- WE ALSO HAVE TO
CONSIDER- BACK CALL WHEN WE'RE
DOING THESE UPGRADES TO FIVE G.
AND RUDY I'M NOT GONNA TOUCH
TOO MUCH ON THAT LAST NOW
BECAUSE I THINK HE DID A VERY
NICE JOB IN. COVERING THAT- BUT
I WOULD SAY THAT- WHEN WE'RE
DEPLOYING FIVE G. AND EVEN
FORTY- BACK CALL IS DEFINITELY
SOMETHING THAT WE CONSIDER AND
WE NEED TO UPGRADE ALONG. THE
WAY- ONE OF THE THINGS I IS
IMPORTANT TO. OUT AND TO ADD IN
IT JUST TO WHAT HE HAD STATED
THAT NOT ALL CARE YOUR HAVE
THEIR OWN BACK CENTER IN SOME
THEY ARE ADEPT ON THIRD
PARTIES- TWO WEEKS STEP BACK
CALL FROM. AND SO- THAT CREATES
A NEED FOR US TO HAVE SOMETIMES
HAVE TO DEPEND ON- PERMITTING
JERSEY IN ORDER TO MAKE SURE
THAT THAT HAPPENS- AND WE CAN
IN THE FUTURE DO SMART PLANNING
DECISIONS THAT HELP HELP WITH
THAT SO I'LL EXPLAIN THAT IN A
SECOND BUT IS FAR FIVE GT-
NETWORKS AND CARRIERS- LOOK AT
DOMINATION OF THE SITE IN THERE
NOW SO FOR THE MOST PART- WE
HAVE WHAT IS CALLED THE MATTER
SITE- LARGER DEPLOYMENTS WE
HAVE SMALL CELLS THAT AND
SOMETIMES ARE FOUND IN THE
PUBLIC RIGHT AWAY. AND THEN WE
HAVE DASCOM'S THAT ARE FOUND IN
OUR EVENT SPACES- WE NEED WHEN
WE'RE DECIDING WHAT TO EAT-
DEPLOYED IN THOSE APPLICATIONS
WE LOOK AT THE COVERAGE AND
CAPACITY NEEDS AND READING ALSO
MENTIONED THAT THE LAST PANEL
WHICH I THOUGHT WAS GOOD. THEN
WHEN WE'RE DECIDING ON HOW TO
DESIGN THE NETWORK OR WHAT TO
DEPLOY WE'RE LOOKING AT
POPULATION DENSITY AND ALSO AT
THE USERS THAT MIGHT BE ON THE
NETWORK WHEN WE'RE MAKING THOSE.
DECISIONS- WHEN WE'RE UP THESE
AT THIS THANK BE IN VARIOUS
LOOKING SOME ARE OBVIOUSLY LOOK
IN RESIDENTIAL AREAS COMMERCIAL
AREAS AND AS I MENTIONED EVENT
SPACES- SO ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT- AS FAR AS NETWORK AND
FIND A FIVE JEAN DOING
EXPEDITIOUSLY. AND THAT WE CAN
CONSIDER GOING FOR IN FUTURE IS
SMART PLANNING SO LOOKING AT
WHERE WE WANT. THE TECHNOLOGY
TO GO INTO THE CHURCH AND
MAKING SURE THAT WHEN WE'RE
DOING OUR PLANNING AND WORK-
SUBMITTING TO JURISDICTIONS ARE
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS THAT WE'RE
THINKING ABOUT WHAT. WE COULD
DO YOU TO ANTICIPATE WHAT IS
COMING NEXT AND THAT COULD BE-
UNDER A SMART PLAY ANY MODEL
WHERE YOU PARTNER WITH
JURISDICTIONS TO DETERMINE.
WHAT COULD BE PROVIDED IN
ADVANCE OF THE TECHNOLOGY BEING
ADDED TO THE SITE SO THAT IT
WOULD CUT DOWN ON THE TIME THAT
WE TAKE TO GO THROUGH THE
PERMITTING PROCESS- ANOTHER
THING THAT WAS MENTIONED ON THE
PANEL THAT I THINK IT'S-
IMPORTANT TO REITERATE. IS
THAT- FIVE G. IS IT CANCER
MOBILE BROADBAND RIGHT. SO-
INTENTIONALLY ONE HAPPEN OF
OVER NETWORK WILL ALLOW
INDIVIDUALS TO PRETTY MUCH HAVE
BOB AND AT THE DISPOSAL AS THE
TRAVELED THROUGHOUT DAY WITH
DEVICE THEY HAVE SO IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT TO SUPPORT AND
UPGRADE OUR NETWORKS TO SUPPORT
ALL THE ADDITIONAL USERS RP
YOU. BETTER BE ABLE TO USE OUR
SERVICES FOR MANY MANY
DIFFERENT ASPECTS OF LIFE HELLO
THE OTHER THING I WANTED TO
TOUCH UPON YOU- IN THE
CONVERSATION OF THE NETWORK
UPGRADES IS THAT- SPIKY SPEEDS
ARE FASTER AS MENTIONED BEFORE-
LATENCY ISN'T IMPROVED AND SO
ASK PEOPLE TRAVEL THROUGHOUT
THEIR DAY- THERE OBVIOUSLY
USING YOUR DEVICES FOR MANY
THINGS. AND SO OF THE NETWORK
AND THE INFRASTRUCTURE AND THE
NETWORK HAS TO BE ABLE TO
SUPPORT ALL THE PIECES BACK ON
PEOPLE ARE CURRENTLY HAVING-
THAT ARE USING FOR THEIR
DEVICES SO IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT THAT- WE ARE
SUPPORTING THE NETWORK UPGRADES
WERE DOING IT QUICKLY AND WE'RE
BEING ABLE TO MEET OUR
CUSTOMERS DEMANDS. I WANTED TO
TALK ABOUT I'M KIND OF HOW- THE
MOBILE AND THEN OTHER CARRIERS
ARE LOOKING AT WHAT FIVE G.
LOOKS LIKE FOR THAT. SO AS
MENTIONED I THINK ON OTHER
PANELS- MANY YEARS HAVE DECIDED
TO DEPLOY FIVE G. AND A LOW
BAND MID BAND AND- HIGH BAND
SPECTRUM AND FOR T. MOBILE AND
AS MANY OF YOU KNOW THERE WAS
A- A RECENT MERGER WITH SPRINT
THAT GAVE US THE ABILITY TO
HAVE ACCESS. TO TWO POINT FIVE
OR MID BAND SPECTRUM. OF MID
BAND SPECTRUM IT'S IMPORTANT
FOR ALL CHARACTERS IN ORDER TO
BE ABLE TO ADVANCE AND TO ADD
ON INTO YOUR INTO. THE FIVE G.
PLAN FOR THE FUTURE SO IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT ALL CARRIERS
HAVE ACCESS TO ALL OF THOSE
THREE LAYERS AND FOR T. MOBILE
THE MERGER PROVIDED US ACCESS
TO THE TWO POINT FIVE.
MEGAHERTZ AS WE CONTINUE TO GO
DOWN THE PATH TO FIVE G. WE ARE
GOING. OBVIOUSLY NEED THE
SUPPORT AT AS YOU KNOW AT THE
SPECTRUM BACK WE NEED IN ORDER
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE CAN DEPLOY
A FIVE G. G. TO ALL CUSTOMERS
AND ALL PLACES AND THAT
SPECTRUM. OBVIOUSLY WE GET FROM
OPTIONS BUT I WANTED TO MENTION
THAT BECAUSE THERE'S A LAYER
APPROACH TO FIVE G. DEPLOYMENTS
AND NETWORKS AND SO IT'S A LOW
BAND BIG BAND AND- HIGH BAND
PLAY THERE ARE WHEN WE- ARE
DEPLOYING THESE NETWORK
UPGRADES- WE OFTEN TIMES HAVE
TO PARTNER WITH LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS AND ALTHOUGH- THE
FEDERAL COMMUNICATIONS
COMMISSION CLARIFIED AND HAS
MODIFIED A KEY ELEMENTS OF
INFRASTRUCTURE REGULATION
OBVIOUSLY AT THE STATE AND
LOCAL LEVELS WE NEED THE
SUPPORT OF AS OF. LEGISLATION
AT THAT LEVEL ND PULSE YOU
KNOW OBVIOUSLY ORDINANCE-
CHANGES AND CONSIDERATIONS TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE ABLE TO
DEPLOY A FIVE G. EXPEDITIOUSLY
I'M SOME OF THE WAYS THAT WE
LOOK AT AS THE WIRELESS
INDUSTRY TO BE ABLE TO PARTNER
WITH A LOCAL JURISDICTIONS TO
BE ABLE DEPLOY. QUICKLY AS
POSSIBLE IS- WE REALLY WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE BALANCING
THE NEEDS OF THE COMMUNITY
AGAINST THE NEEDS OF THE
WIRELESS INDUSTRY AND ALSO
MAKING SURE THAT WE CAN DEPLOY
QUICKLY- SOME AREAS IN WHICH
WE'VE SEEN THAT IT'S THEIR VERY
IT'S VERY POSITIVE. FOR US TO
MOVE FORWARD EXPEDITIOUSLY IS
MIND JURISDICTIONS CONSIDER
OBVIOUSLY FROM AN AESTHETIC
IMPACT THAT CERTAIN FACILITIES
ARE ALREADY CONCEALED ARE
ALREADY ARE BEHIND SCREENING-
AND THEREFORE AND THE POINT
QUICKLY THROUGH HAVING A-
SHORTENED REVIEW PROCESS IS
VERY HELPFUL WHEN YOU'RE TRYING
TO. GET FIVE G. MARKETS INTO
MARKET AS FAST AS WE CAN SO
PARTNERING WITH JURISDICTIONS
AND MAKING SURE THAT THEY
UNDERSTAND THAT WE DO HAVE GOOD
FACILITIES THAT ARE ALREADY- IN
IN THE JURISDICTIONS AND THAT
THE UPGRADES THAT WERE ASKING
FOR ARE GOING TO JUST BE A
MINOR UPGRADES AND NOT. DO NOT
HAVE AN AESTHETIC IMPACT AND
SHOULD BE DEPLOYED QUICKLY- I'M
ALSO LIKE I MENTIONED BEFORE
SMART I THINK IT'S A GREAT OUR
NUMBER JURISDICTIONS I THINK
IT'S VERY HELPFUL TO DEPLOY
FIVE G. AS FAST AS WE CAN AND
THAT WOULD BE TO MAKE SURE THAT
IN ADVANCE STEP UP AS THE
TECHNOLOGY CONTINUES TO GROW ON
THE DIFFERENT DEPARTMENTS THAT
I MENTIONED BEFORE THAT WE
PLANNED- FOR MAYBE. CALL. AND-
THAT THE STREET MAYBE WITH
STREETS OVER UP YOU KNOW
STREETS WE DETERMINED THAT
THERE MY BE AND I FOR US TO
PROVIDE THE FACT HALL THERE
WERE IN THE IS A SMALL CELLS
ATTEND ARMS OWNED EACH WE HAVE
COSTS FACT WAYS TO BE ABLE TO
DO THAT BY GETTING BACK IN
FIRST READY FOR- WHAT WILL
BECOME YEAH NOW AND THOSE ARE
SOWAYS TO PARTNER WITH THE
LOCAL ENTITIES TO ENSURE THAT
WERE ABLE TO W. G. TECHNOLOGIES
BUT HIS AND IN SOME CASES-
ALTHOUGH WE KNOW THAT THINGS
CHANGE- AND WE ALL HAVE TO BE
AGILE- LOCAL JURISDICTIONS WORK
WITH THE SOMETIMES IT'S THINGS
IT'S GOOD TO PARTNER THEM TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE CAN IMPLEMENT
NEW RULES AND POLICIES QUICKLY-
SO THAT WE'RE ABLE TO DEPLOY AS
FAST AS YOU CAN FOR THE
WIRELESS INDUSTRY AND ALSO TO
GET THE FULL BENEFITS OF WHAT
FIVE G. CAN OFFER TO ASK. SO
THOSE ARE THE MAIN POINTS THAT
I WANTED TO HIT ON ON THIS FAR
AS- THE- DEPLOYMENT FOR FIVE G.
THANK YOU MUCH PARKER FOR YOUR
PRESENTATION LETTUCE- NEXT GO
TO MR JEFF NEAL- LEGISLATIVE
REPRESENTATIVE WITH THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES THERE'S NO FOR THE
SPARE CARE MEMBERS JEFF MIGLIOR
WITH THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES
REPRESENTING ALL FIFTY EIGHT
COUNTIES IN CALIFORNIA I THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK TODAY. FIVE TWO MAIN
POINTS I'D LIKE TO MAKE FIRST
WE'VE HEARD TODAY ABOUT THE
MANY BENEFITS FIVE G. WILL
BRING TO CALIFORNIANS AND SAY
COUNTIES ARE EXCITED ABOUT THE
NEW POSSIBILITIES FIVE G. WILL
BRING FOR PROVIDING GOVERNMENT
SERVICES. M. BUT IT'S WORTH
NOTING AS THE PREVIOUS
PANELISTS HAVE THAT THESE
BENEFITS CAN ONLY BE REALIZED
IF THEY'RE SUFFICIENT FIBER
AVAILABLE ALL INTERNET
CONNECTIONS WHETHER WIRED OR
MOBILE COME BACK TO FIGHT FOR.
THE RIGHT NOW THOUGH MILLIONS
OF CALIFORNIANS ARE WITHOUT ANY
ACCESS TO BROADBAND FOR THAT
EXACT REASON A LACK OF FIBER SO
WHILE DEPLOYED IMPROVE
TECHNOLOGY FOR THOSE WHO ARE
ALREADY CONNECTED IS A GOOD
THING. WE SHOULD KEEP THOSE
BENEFITING IN CONTEXT. I IT IS
AN ISSUE JULIE YOU IN RURAL
AREA AND WELL AS URBAN THAT ARE
ALL ACT JUST AND HISTORICALLY
BEEN THE SUBJECT OF
DISCRIMINATION. SB ONE FIFTY
SIX THOUGH WHICH THE
LEGISLATURE PASSED EARLIER THIS
SUMMER WILL GO A LONG WAY
EQUALIZING ACCESS BY BOTH-
PROVIDING BILLIONS OF DOLLARS
OF SUBSIDIES. FOR HIGH SPEED
LAST MILE FIBRE INFRASTRUCTURE-
BUT ALSO CRITICALLY BY BUILDING
A STATE OWNED MIDDLE MILE FIBER
NETWORK I THAT WILL BE OPEN TO
ALL PROVIDERS ON NON
DISCRIMINATORY TERMS. AND WHICH
WILL SIGNIFICANTLY REDUCE THE
COST AND THE TIME FOR THEM TO
BUILD OUT THEIR NETWORKS TO ALL
CALIFORNIANS I THE OTHER
IMPORTANT ISSUE WOULD LIKE TO.
IS THE QUESTION OF HOW TO
BALANCE THE DESIRE FOR QUICK
EXPANSION OF FIVE G.
INFRASTRUCTURE WITH WITH BOTH
THE LAND USE AUTHORITY IN
PUBLIC SAFETY CONCERNS OF THE
COUNTIES AND CITIES THAT ARE
CHARGED WITH THOSE
RESPONSIBILITIES FOR THEIR
COMMUNITIES- AND ALSO WITH OUR
GENUINE DESIRE FOR COMMUNITIES.
AT ALL OF THEM TO HAVE ACCESS
TO HIGH SPEED SERVICE BY
CONNECTING FIVE G. WITH THE
POLICY LOOKING BACKWARD AS FAR
AND THE PROVIDE BUILDING THIS
INFRASTRUCTURE HIM IS SIMPLE
PROMISE THAT THAT ADAM THESE
EFFORTS AND VISIBLY THAT PERMIT
STREAMLINING AND REDUCE
REGULATIONS WILL LEAD NOT ONLY
TO FASTER DEPLOYMENT BUT TO
MORE WIDESPREAD DEPLOYMENT. AND
SPECIFICALLY ROOT CANAL PER
AREA THAT ARE CURRENTLY
UNSERVED AND UNDERSERVED YOU
HEARD IT TODAY AT THAT FIVE G.
WILL SOLVE THE LAST MILE PART
OF THE DIGITAL DIVIDE TO DO
THAT THE DENSITY OF SMALL CELLS
NECESSARY FOR FIVE G. TO WORK
IS MUCH GREATER THE ARGUMENTS
FOR UNFETTERED ACCESS TO
UTILITY POLES AND TRAFFIC LIGHT
POLES PARTNERSHIPS WITH THE
LOCAL AGENCIES. BUT INCREASE
DENSITY DOESN'T EXACTLY LEND
ITSELF TO DEPLOYMENT IN AREAS
WHERE THE PEOPLE ARE NOT
DENSELY SO WHAT WILL FIVE G. BE
THE ANSWER TO YOUR BIG WHAT IS
BROADBAND IN RURAL AREAS OR AND
OR OR SUBURBAN AREAS THAT ARE
NOT DENSELY POPULATED M. AS THE
PREVIOUS BALANCE THAT THE FCC
HAS PROMULGATED REGULATIONS
ONCE THE STATE IS AS EXPAND
OURS CONSIDERING FURTHER
EXPANSION OF. THE INCIDENT
REDUCE MARKET BARRIERS AND
INCENTIVIZE THE DEPLOYMENT OF A
WIRELESS AND CABLE
COMMUNICATIONS FACILITIES THE
FCC RULES PROVIDE FOR STRINGENT
TIME LIMITS ARE SHOT CLOCKS THE
CITING OF WIRELESS FACILITIES
BY LOCAL GOVERNMENTS. AND IT
REQUIRES LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO
ALLOW NON DISCRIMINATORY ACCESS
TO PUBLIC INFRASTRUCTURE IN THE
PUBLIC RIGHT AWAY- A TO AN
UNPRECEDENTED DEGREE I'M SO I
THINK THE THAT THE LEGISLATURE
WILL WANT TO KEEP IN MIND GOING
FORWARD IS WHETHER THE
DEREGULATION THAT HAS BEEN
GRANTED IN FACT RESULTS IN
IMPROVED CONNECTIONS FOR THE-
GROW AREAS FOR ECONOMICALLY
DISADVANTAGED WORK ON THE
CONTRARY IF. WHETHER DEPLOYMENT
IS LARGELY CENTERED IN
COMMUNITIES THAT ARE ALREADY
WELL CONNECTED WITH ANY OTHER
AREAS EVEN FARTHER BEHIND
BECAUSE- FRANKLY WHEN CARD IS
EXACT SAME ARGUMENTS IN THE
PAST WE HEARD OF FOR EXAMPLE
WITH THE PASSAGE OF OBJECT THAT
THE DIGITAL INFRASTRUCTURE TO
BE A COMPETITION ACT IN TWO
THOUSAND SIX. AND THE RESULTS
DID NOT EXACTLY LIVE UP TO THE
PROMISES AND UBIQUITOUS ACCESS
CHEAPER SERVICE AND MORE
COMPETITION. IN SO IF FIVE G.
DEPLOYMENT FOLLOWS THE SAME
PATTERN WE'VE SEEN BEFORE AFTER
THE PREVIOUS ROUNDS OF IMPROVED
MOBILE COVERAGE AND FIBRE
BROADBAND DEPLOYMENT THAT WILL
WHAT POLICY MAKERS HAVE LOST
THEIR OPPORTUNITY TO USE PERMIT
STREAMLINING AS AN INCENTIVE TO
ENCOURAGE WORK REQUIRE.
EQUITABLE DEPLOYMENT BECAUSE
ONCE THE FACILITIES ARE
REPORTED IN THE MOST LUCRATIVE
AREAS THAT LEVERAGE WILL BE
GONE SO TO SUMMARIZE FIRST THAT
THE BENEFITS OF FIVE G. ARE
ONLY AVAILABLE IN THE FIBER AND
THE NEWLY APPROVED A STATE
OWNED OPEN ACCESS MIDDLE MILE
NETWORK WILL SIGNIFICANTLY
INCREASE THE AVAILABILITY OF
FIBRE DECREASE THE COST OF
EXPANDING. LAST MILE NETWORKS
FOR ALL PROVIDERS SO IT'S
IMPORTANT FOR THE STATE TO
FOLLOW THROUGH ON THE POLICIES
IMPLEMENTED WITH THE PASSAGE SB
ONE FIFTY SIX. SECOND THE
DEREGULATION PERMIT
STREAMLINING ALREADY AND ALL
ALLOW PROVIDERS UNPRECEDENTED
INEXPENSIVE ACCESS TO PUBLIC
INFRASTRUCTURE AND WE URGE THE
LEGISLATURE TO MONITOR-
IMPORTANT WHETHER THIS
DEREGULATION IN FACT LEADS TO A
MORE EQUITABLE ACCESS TO
BROADBAND WITH IT NEARLY
LOWERS. THE COST TO DEPLOY THE
IMPROVE TECHNOLOGY IN AREAS
THAT ARE WELCOME. WE CERTAINLY
HAVE HIGH HOPES THAT THIS NEW
GENERATION OF TECHNOLOGY WILL
RESULT IN A MORE CONNECTING
CALIFORNIA. AND WE BELIEVE THAT
THE APPROPRIATE ROLE OF
GOVERNMENT IS TO BOTH PROVIDE
PUBLIC INFRASTRUCTURE FOR THE
PUBLIC GOOD AND TO PROVIDE
APPROPRIATE OVERSIGHT TO MAKE
SURE THAT THAT HAPPENS THANK
YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
YOUR PRESENTATION I HEALTH A
FEW FOLLOW UP QUESTIONS FOR THE
PANEL. IF I MAY OUR. OKAY SORRY.
BEFORE WE GO TO QUESTIONS SO
LET'S GO TO AUTHORED PANELISTS
TO MR ROBERT TRIP ME THE THIRD.
THANK YOU COMMITTEE CHAIR CHAU
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE I
HAVE THE UNENVIABLE POSITION OF
STANDING BETWEEN YOU AND YOUR
LUNCH BUT I ALSO HAVE THE
BENEFIT OF BATTING CLEANUP SO.
I LIKE TO START OFF BY SAYING I
AGREE WITH A LOT OF THINGS THAT
THESE TEAM MEMBERS OF THE PANEL
THAT CAME BEFORE ME SO. FIVE G.
HAS A LOT OF PROMISE AND THERE
ARE LOTS OF ELEGANT SOLUTIONS
TO DIFFICULT PROBLEMS THAT
PLAGUE. OUR NETWORK
CONNECTIVITY OR NETWORK
SECURITY AND OUR SOCIAL ACCESS
TO THESE SERVICES THAT HAVE
BECOME ESSENTIALLY A UTILITY
WHAT I'M HERE TO DO TODAY IS
TALK ABOUT SOME PRACTICAL
IMPACTS- THAT ARE EXPECTING
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS. AT THE
DEPLOYMENT STAGE SO. ONE OF THE
THINGS YOU HEARD- AT THE FIRST
PANEL AND I THINK IT WAS DR
GUPTA WHO SAID. THAT ADOPTION
IS LUMPY WELL DEPLOYMENT IS
LUCKY TO. AND IT'S PARTIALLY
BECAUSE OF LIMITED REGULATORY
WHIPLASH SO WE'VE HAD A DECADES
OLD REGULATORY FRAMEWORK ISSUED
BY THE TELECOMMUNICATIONS ACT
AND WE'VE HAD RECENTLY AS OF
TWENTY NINETEEN A LOT OF
CHANGES COMING FROM THE FCC
ABOUT HOW FAST WERE SUPPOSED TO
ADOPT CERTAIN REGULATIONS. HOW
QUICKLY WERE SUPPOSED TO
APPROVE CERTAIN PERMITS AND HOW
MUCH MONEY LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
CAN CHARGE FOR THE SERVICES
THEY PROVIDE IN THE PERMITTING
PROCESS. AND THAT CREATES SOME
PROBLEMS NUMBER ONE. IS A
RESOURCE ALLOCATION PROBLEM.
WIRELESS IT IS IMPORTANT ROBIN
AND IS VERY IMPORTANT BUT THEREARE LOTS OF OTHER IMPORTANT
ISSUES AND LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
FACE AND MANY PLANNING OR EVEN
PUBLIC WORKS DEPARTMENTS IN THE
STATE HAVE ONLY MAYBE ONE.
MEMBER OF THEIR STAFF. AND ONE
HUNDRED NETWORKING UP ON TOP OF
AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND OTHER
TYPES OF PROJECTS THAT ARE
PRETTY IMPORTANT OUR
LEGISLATIVE AGENDA SO IF WE
WANT LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO BE
ABLE TO MOVE QUICKLY- THEY NEED
TO BE PROPERLY STAFFED. AND
THAT ALSO REQUIRES TIME BECAUSE
IN ORDER TO MAKE SURE THAT
THERE ARE HANDS AVAILABLE TO
MOVE THESE APPLICATIONS THROUGH
THE PROCESS WE'VE GOT TO BE
READY WITH THOSE HANDS. FIND
THE PEOPLE THAT ARE NECESSARY
TO A CABLE ACCEPTING THESE
APPLICATIONS REVIEWING THAT
PROCESSING THEM MAKING A
RECOMMENDATION ABOUT APPROVAL
IT IT ALSO REQUIRES TIME ON THE
FRONT SO THERE'S A BIT OF A
WIND UP WHEN IT COMES TO
CHANGING HOW WE PROCESS THESE
APPLICATIONS WE WENT FROM
ZONING HEAVY TYPE OF REVIEW
PROCESS BEFORE TWENTY NINETY.
TO A MORE ADMINISTRATIVE LESS
HEARING HEAVY TYPE PROCESS
AFTER TWENTY G. AND IN MANY
CASES THE TIME IT TAKES TO
PROCESS AN APPLICATION UNDER
WHAT THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
CALLED SHOT CLOCK CAN BE LONGER
THAN THE TIME IT TAKES I'M
SORRY SHORTER THAN THE TIME IT
TAKES. TO ADOPT NEW REGULATIONS
AND ALLOW CITIES TO PROCESS
THESE APPLICATIONS ON
ADMINISTRATIVE BASIS SO GIVING
US TIME AND RESOURCES WOULD
HELP IN ADAPTING TO THE CHANGES
IN TECHNOLOGY AND REGULATION
THAT WE'RE SEEING. FROM THE
STATE AND FEDERAL LEVEL AND
FROM PRIVATE INDUSTRY AND IT'S
NOT NECESSARILY A BAD THING
IT'S JUST UNNECESSARY INPUT TO
THAT PROCESS AND I HEARD FOR
EXAMPLE MISS PARKER FROM T.
MOBILE TALK ABOUT THE SMART
PROCESS AND I THINK THAT'S
GREAT. A LOT OF OUR CLIENTS
HAVE ADOPTED. PROCESS SEES
WITHIN THE BOUNDARIES OF THEIR
AUTHORITY BECAUSE MUCH OF THEIR
THIRTIES BEEN TAKEN AWAY BUT
WITHIN THE BOUNDARIES OF THEIR
AUTHORITY. TO CREATE WHAT THEY
CALL PRE APPROVALS. RIGHT IF
THE CARRIER WANTS TO COME IN
AND TALK TO THEM ABOUT A DESIGN
THAT IS REPLICABLE. THROUGH
COMMUNITY I AT THE LOCAL LEVEL
THAT TAKES AWAY A LOT OF THE
THOUGHT PROCESS THAT GOES INTO
THE NORMAL REVIEW. THAT WE WANT
TO. WORK WITH THEM SHOULD A
STABBER STYLE AND THEN MOVE
THAT FORWARD AS A PRE APPROVAL
THAT COULD BE REPLICATED OVER
AND OVER AGAIN REALLY
STREAMLINING THAT PROCESS BUT
THAT. STILL TAKES TIME THE
OTHER THING I WANTED TO MENTION
WAS THAT YOU HEARD ABOUT REALLY
ELEGANT SOLUTIONS ABOUT.
AVOIDING THE EXPENSE AND TIME
THAT IT TAKES TO DEPLOY FIBER.
IN AREAS THAT ARE HARD TO
REACH. AND THAT IS A VERY
DIFFICULT PROBLEM- THESE ARE
PRIVATE ENTITIES. THE ANSWER TO
THEIR SHAREHOLDERS AND SO IT'S
NOT. GOING TO GIVE THEM A
RETURN ON INVESTMENT TO SEND
FIBER OR INVESTMENT DOLLARS OUT
TO RURAL AREA THEY JUST WON'T
DO IT AND WE'VE SEEN THAT
HAPPEN OVER AND OVER AGAIN I
THINK. MISTER NEAL MADE THAT
POINT PRETTY WELL. UP THERE
ARE. WIRELESS BACKHAUL OPTIONS
THAT I THINK MAKES SENSE.
WHAT'S POWER WAS STILL AN
ISSUE. AND IN URBAN AREAS WHERE
THERE AREDIGITAL DIVIDES.
THERE ARE STILL FIBER OPTIONS
THAT REQUIRE THE CARRIERS TO
CUT UP THE STREETS. AND CUTTING
UP THE STREETS IS ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT INSTEAD IS A LOT OF
HARPER- NOT JUST BECAUSE- OF
SOMETHING YOU READ IN YOUR
PACKET ABOUT THE MORATORIUM
WATER SAYING THAT WE CANNOT.
PROHIBIT THE DEPLOYMENT OF
THESE TYPES OF FACILITIES THERE
ARE SOME AGAIN ELEGANT
SOLUTIONS LIKE MICROSTRATEGY
INC THAT REDUCE THE IMPACT ON
THE STREETS. BUT WHEN YOU'VE
GOT A HALF DOZEN OR A DOZEN
ENTITIES AT ALL ONE MICRO
TRENCHING THROUGH ONE SIDE OF
THE STREET. THE FACT THEY'RE
DOIN TWELVE INCH CUTS OVER AND
OVER AND OVER AGAIN DOESN'T
REALLY MAKE SENSE WHEN YOU
COULD BE DOING ONE LARGE
STRETCH IT WE CAN'T FORCE THEM
INTO THAT SITUATION. SOWE ARE
DEALING WITH- THE EXTERNALITIES
OF PHYSICAL ONE. AND IT DOESN'T
JUST AND THAT WELL HOW MANY
DIFFERENT CUTS READ HAPPENED
STREET ENDS ALSO WITH. WHAT
HAPPENS TO THE STREET IF THERE
ARE IMPROPER. CONSTRUCTION
METHODS SO I'M REPRESENT A LOT
OF CITIES IN CALIFORNIA I'M NOT
HERE SPEAKING FOR ANY ONE OF
THEM BUT I CAN TELL YOU. THAT
THERE ARE A HANDFUL OF LAWSUITS
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
RIGHT NOW HOW DO YOU FIND TO
CLOSE. GOING OVER THE
HANDLEBARS BECAUSE THEY RAN
INTO A TRENCH THAT FAIL AND FOR
A CITY THAT DEALS WITH THAT
KIND OF ISSUE IT CAUSES THEM TO
POSIT THE DEPLOYMENT STAGE
BECAUSE WE HAVE TO TALK ABOUT
INSURANCE AND THEN WE HAVE TO
TALK ABOUT INDEMNITY FOR ISSUES
ABOUT CONSTRUCTION THAT WE
CAN'T SAY YES OR NO WHERE WE
ARE I'M SORRY WE CAN'T SAY NO
TO WE HAVE TO SAY YES TO THESE
TYPES OF DEPLOYMENTS IN MANY
INSTANCES. AND THEN WE HAVE TO
DEAL WITH THOSE EXTERNALITIES
LATER THESE ARE MULTI MILLION
DOLLAR JUDGMENTS THAT WERE
POTENTIALLY FACING HERE SO. I
THINK STREAMLINING LOCAL
GOVERNMENT PROCESS SEES IS
CERTAINLY PART OF THE EQUATION.
BUT IN ORDER TO DO THAT WE HAVE
TO BE ABLE TO WORK WITH OUR
PARTNERS AND USED THE SITE. TO
COME UP WITH A SOLUTION THAT
MAKES SENSE THAT THAT DOES
REQUIRE TIME AND RESOURCES. WE
ALSO HAVE TO REDUCE THOSE
EXTERNALITIES THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS MIGHT HAVE TO
OTHERWISE ASSUME OR AT LEAST
FACE. THE POSSIBILITY OF
LIABILITY FOR WHEN IT COMES TO
CUTTING UP THE STREETS FOR ALL
THE POWER AND FIBER THAT'S
REQUIRED TO. GET HOW LIGHT UP
THESE FACILITIES UP BEYOND THAT
I THINK THAT THE REST OF THE
PANEL IS THAT A VERY GOOD JOB
OF HIGHLIGHTING WHAT THESE
THINGS ARE GOOD FOR. ALL RIGHT
I'LL JUST MOMENTS BECAUSE THEY
SAY THAT LOCAL GOVERNMENTS ARE
GENERALLY IN FAVOR OF THIS KIND
OF TECHNOLOGICAL REVOLUTION
THEY SEE THE BENEFITS THAT
COULD COME TO THEM DOWN THE
PIPELINE WHAT WE HAVE A HARD
TIME WITH IS UNDERSTANDING HOW
WE CAN PARTICIPATE WITH SO MANY
OF US ARE ARE- LEVERAGE WITH
THE LOWER EAST OR PROPERTY
RIGHTS BEING TAKEN AWAY FROM US
MOSTLY BY THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT THESE DAYS. BUT WE
WOULD LIKE TO WORK MORE CLOSELY
WITH OUR PARTNERS ON THE
INDUSTRY SIDE TO ACCOMPLISH ALL
THE GOALS HAVE BEEN TALKED HERE
TODAY AND SO IF THERE'S
SOMETHING THAT CAN BE DONE AT
THAT LEVEL WE CERTAINLY OPEN
TO. I WILL BE HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR YOUR PRESENTATION I DO
HAVE A FEW FOLLOW UP QUESTIONS
IF I MAY. OF FIRST OF ALL THIS
IS THE SOMEWHAT OF A TWO PART
QUESTION. ARE IS THERE
SOMETHING AS- AS A SATURATION
POINT WHEN IT COMES TO THE
DEPLOYMENT OF FIVE G. NETWORK
AND WHEN THE LEGISLATURE
CONSIDERS POLICY IN FIVE G.
RELATED ISSUES OKAY WE OPERATE
UNDER THE ASSUMPTION THAT THE
NEXT GENERATION WILL REQUIRE.
MORE CELLS IN CLOSER PROXIMITY
TO ONE ANOTHER WHETHER IT'S
URBAN OR RULE OR OTHERWISE. I
THINK I CAN TAKE A SHOT AT THAT
SURE- I THINK THE- AS FAR AS IS
THERE A SATURATION POINT- I
DON'T KNOW THAT RIGHT NOW THAT
THERE IS RIGHT. ESPECIALLY FIVE
G. BEING DEPLOYED AS A NEWER
TECHNOLOGY- WE HAVE A LONG WAY
TO GO BEFORE THERE'S A
SATURATION POINT THERE HOWEVER
I DO YOU- WANT TO KIND OF POINT
OUT SOME THINGS THAT ACTUALLY-
ARE USEFUL WITH THE FIVE G.
TECHNOLOGY WHERE WE DIDN'T
NECESSARILY HAVE THE CAPABILITY
WITH FOUR G. M. WE'RE ABLE TO.
SLICE OF SPECTRUM AND BE ABLE
TO MAKE IT WORK A FURTHER AND
LONGER IN THE WRK WITH- FOR
JEEP WHICH END UP HELPING US IN
HOW AND WHERE WE DEPLOY FIVE G.
AND- WHICH SITES WE DECIDED TO
UPGRADE WITH THIS TECHNOLOGY SO
I THINK IT ACTUALLY IS MORE
HELPFUL THE WAY THAT WE ARE
ABLE TO- PIECE OF. THE SPECTRUM
THAT WE ALREADY HAVE AVAILABLE
FOR USE AND MAKE IT ACTUALLY
WORK FURTHER FOR US
ADDITIONALLY I THINK OF WHEN I
WAS HAVING THE DISCUSSION ABOUT
LOW BAND MID BAND AND HIGH BAND
I WANTED TO EXPLAIN THAT LOW
BAND- THAT TECHNOLOGY- HELPED
US A LITTLE BIT MORE WITH
INDOOR AND INTEGRATION. MID
BAND- IS HELPING US WITH INDOOR
AND OUTDOOR PENETRATION BUT
IT'S FOR. A LONGER DISTANCE AND
THEM HI B. AND IS VERY SHORT
DISTANCES OF THE LINE OF SIGHT
TO THE NEXT SITE HAS TO BE
PRETTY CLEAR WITH NO
OBSTRUCTION THERE SO- PART OF
THAT LAYERED APPROACH THAT I.
TALKED ABOUT THAT MOST CARRIERS
ARE ARE SEARCHING FOR AS A
STRATEGY IS TO HELP TO KIND OF
BRIDGE THE GAPS BETWEEN THOSE
THREE OBJECTIVES FOR OUR
CUSTOMERS AND SO THERE BY. IT
WILL IT. MAY NOT RESULT IN
HAVING HAVE A SAY EVERY I THINK
A LOT OF THE IS THAT WE GOING
TO HAVE TO HAVE A SITE AND
OTHER RIGHT AND BY AGAIN THAT
TECHNOLOGY GIVES US THE ABILITY
TO LOOK AT OF THE
INFRASTRUCTURE WE ARE WE DO
NEED TO ADDRESS- WHERE IS INTO
IT AND IT'S NOT THE SAME
EVERYWHERE RIGHT BASED ON WHAT
WE ALREADY HAPPENED OUR
EXISTING INFRASTRUCTURE. I HOPE
THAT ANSWERS THE QUESTION GREAT
THANK YOU OTHER PANELS SO IF
WE'RE CHINA FOR LIKE. WELL I'LL
JUST I'LL JUST ADD THAT PERHAPS
SOMEBODY WITH THE HONORIFIC DR
IN FRONT OF THE NEXT PROBABLY
IF YOU'RE BETTER THAN I CAN
THERE'S A LIMITED CAPACITY OF
SPECTRUM- THAT IT IS ABLE TO
TRANSPORT DATA. AND I THINK ONE
OF THE THINGS MISS PARKER WAS
TRYING TO HARP ON IS THAT YOU
CAN HAVE SOFTWARE- BEHIND THE
PHYSICAL HARDWARE THAT CREATES
EXCESS CAPACITY DOESN'T
NECESSARILY PART OF THE SAME
KINDS. OF SOLUTION AND SO FOR
EXAMPLE JUST TO USE YOU MISS
PARKER IS THE EXACT T. MOBILE
USES. STRAND MOUNTED ANTENNAS
TO OFF LOAD CAPACITY ON TWO OF
A FROM THEIR NETWORKS FOR SMALL
CELLS INSTEAD OF MASSIVE
DEPLOYMENTS OF. THINGS ON PAUSE
YOU STILL DO THINGS ON POLLS
TOO BUT I IT'S THERE ARE LOTS
OF DIFFERENT TOOLS IN THE BOX
AND SO IN TERMS OF THE
SATURATION POINT IT MAY NOT BE
A POLE IN FRONT OF EVERY TIME
WAY- BUT IT CERTAINLY- IS
DEPENDENT UPON THE ABILITY OF
THE INDUSTRY TO. DETERMINE NEW
SOLUTIONS FOR GETTING HIGH
CAPACITY THROUGH THEIR PIPES I
THINK FIBER IS PROBABLY GOING
TO BE ONE OF THE BIGGEST
ANSWERS TO THAT BECAUSE THE
MATTER WHERE YOU GO. THAT DATA
HAS TO FLOW BACK TO THE REST OF
THE NETWORK AT SOME POINT AND
SO FIVE OR TO THE POINT. OF
CONNECTION. IS PROBABLY GOING
TO BE RESOLUTION GREAT THANK
YOU. I THINK I HEARD THE TERM
FOUR GB MENTION A COUPLE TIMES-
BY VARIOUS PANEL AS THE
QUESTION IS ARE THERE ANY
ASPECTS OF THE PHYSICAL
INFRASTRUCTURE OF FIVE G.
NETWORKS THAT THE NEXT
GENERATION OF MOBILE NETWORKS
WILL CERTAINLY- RENDER OBSOLETE
RENDER THIS ONE OBSOLETE. ANY
TAKERS BUT I QUESTION. I MEAN I
I'M GONNA TAKE A STAB AT IT I
DON'T KNOW WEEK SINCE I DON'T
KNOW WHAT SIX GENERATION NEXT
LOOKS LIKE YET I DON'T KNOW
WHAT COULD BE RENDERED OBSOLETE
IN THE FUTURE HOWEVER WHAT I
CAN SAY WHAT WE KNOW FOR SURE.
IS THAT THERE ARE A LOT OF
PLAYERS IN OUR- INFRASTRUCTURE
THAT HAVE EXISTED FOR MANY
YEARS INCLUDING- YOU YES WHICH
WAS THIRD GENERATION. INSTEAD
OF YOUR YOUR STOCK YES SO IT'S
FAR THAT'S GETTING TO THE
OBSOLETE POINT I DO THINK IT
TAKES TIME AS AS THE TECHNOLOGY
EVOLVES TO DETERMINE WHEN WE
WILL GET TO THAT. POINT I DON'T
KNOW THAT FOUR G. WILL WOULD BE
OBSOLETE ANYTIME IN THE IN THE
NEAR FUTURE BUT WE DO HAVE TO
LOOK AT ALL OF THAT. AS
CUSTOMERS THAT WE HAVE IN ALL
OF THE DEVICES THAT ARE
AVAILABLE TO THE CUSTOMERS AND
WHEN WE'RE PLANNING OUR NETWORK
WE DO CONSIDER THAT IN. OF WHAT
TECHNOLOGY NEEDS TO BE ON EACH
INDIVIDUAL SITE SO IF YOU HAVE
A FOUR G. DEVICE CAPABLE DEVICE
AND YOU'RE NOT YET MOVED ONTO
THE FIVE G. CAPABLE DEVICE WE
OBVIOUSLY HAVE TO STILL SERVE
THE CUSTOMER. THAT WE HAVE- I
DON'T KNOW WHAT THE FUTURE
HOLDS- I WOULD IMAGINE THAT- AS
WE KEEP MOVING TECHNOLOGY
FORWARD- AND WE GET A CHANCE
TECHNOLOGY THERE WILL BE. SOME
OF THE TECHNOLOGY FOR THE PAST
WILL BE RENDERED USELESS BUT I
HAVEN'T SEEN IT YET LEAD TO
THAT POINT AND I WORK FOR MORE
THAN EIGHTY IT SB THAT T.
MOBILE WORKED FOR. EIGHTEEN T.
IN THE PAST SO I'VE SEEN A
COUPLE OF DIFFERENT NETWORKS
AND KIND OF HOW THE- THE
INFRASTRUCTURE WORKS AND I
THINK. WE'RE NOT AT THAT POINT
YET BUT HE COULD BE THERE IN.
IN THE FUTURE SHOULD BE SOME
OTHER TECH THAT IT BOB THAT
HOUSES CAN GET RID YEAH ANOTHER
AND OTHER WE CURRENTLY HAVE
THANK I'LL JUST ADD THE CLIENT
PEOPLE HAVE BEEN ASKING ME WHEN
SATELLITES ARE GONNA REPLACE
TERRESTRIAL SYSTEMS FOR LIKE
THE LAST FIVE SIX SEVEN. AND
THE ANSWER IS I DON'T KNOW BUT
I DON'T THINK IT'S GONNA BE
ANYTIME SOON MOSTLY BECAUSE AS
MISS PARKER SAID. PEOPLE ARE
STILL USED AND DEVICES ARE
STILL USE OLDER TECHNOLOGIES
AND SO LONG AS THOSE ARE PART
OF THE ECOSYSTEM MANY ECONOMY
THEY'LL STILL BE SUPPORTED
WHICH REQUIRES SUCH RATIONAL
SYSTEM. SO I DON'T THINK IT'S
GOING TO BE ANY TIME SOON WE'RE
GOING TO SEE A LOSS OF PHYSICAL
INFRASTRUCTURE IN. EITHER IN OR
OUTSIDE RIGHT THANK YOU EARLIER
HURT WE HURT A LITTLE BIT ABOUT
THE FCC REGULATIONS IN SOME OF
THE CHALLENGES THAT- A WE HAVE
WITH THE DEPLOYMENT OF FIVE G.
OF THE MEAT POSED THIS QUESTION
I'M WONDERING WHETHER. COUNTIES
AND FAX CITIES FOR THAT MATTER.
AW HOW CURRENTLY HAVE THE
LATITUDE TO STUDY THE SAFETY
AND HEALTH ISSUES. ALL WITH
RESPECT TO THE DEPLOYMENT OF
CELL TECHNOLOGY I THINK-
PROBABLY. A QUESTION SHE GO TO
MISTER NEAL AND WARM- STRIP
MAYES FOR ANYONE OF THE
PANELISTS IN FACT I'M HAPPY TO.
TAKE A START AT EIGHT AM I
DON'T KNOW THAT THE ROLE OF
COUNTY'S NECESSARILY IS TO
EXAMINE SPECIFICALLY THE HEALTH
EFFECTS ON ON INDIVIDUALS I
THINK. A LOT OF THE TAXES THAT
WE TALK ABOUT THAT WE WORRY
ABOUT WITH DEPLOYMENT
pOF WAY ARE THE PUBLIC SAFETY
ASPECTS OF- YOU KNOW TRAFFIC
CONTROL PLANS- YOU KNOW BAN-
WHEN WERE ABLE TO. YOU KNOW
MAKE SURE THAT ARE OF A POLL IS
EVIL PHYSICALLY ABLE TO TAKE
THE WEIGHT OF A SMALL SALARY
YOU KNOW IN THE NUMBER OF
ATTACHMENTS WE DON'T KNOW HOW
MANY- YOU KNOW COMPANIES WILL
WANT TO DEPLOY IN PARTICULAR
AREAS THERE ARE ONLY SO MANY
HOLES WHAT ONE COMPANY MIGHT
NOT HAVE TO DEPLOY ON EVERY
OTHER POLL. AND IF YOU HAVE A
NUMBER OF DIFFERENT CARRIERS
ALL ONE TO PROVIDE AT YOU KNOW
MISTER IN THE SAME AREA AT SOME
YOU NEED MORE LANES AS MR REYES
WAS SAYING EARLIER AND SO SOME
OF THE PUBLIC AND THAT'S ROBERT
WAS SAYING SOME OF THE PUBLIC
SAFETY ASPECTS LIKE THAT.
BICYCLISTS RUNNING INTO TO
TRENCHES YOU KNOW IT WHAT'S OUR
ABILITY TO. REGULATE THE
DEPLOYMENT AND THAT WAY THANK
ARE A LOT OF THE CONCERNS THAT.
WE YEAH I THINK THAT'S RIGHT I
ON THE CITY SIDE OF THE DAY
TODAY CONCERNED IS. OR IS IT A
POINT SIX. IS A CONSTRUCTION
SAVE IS THE ACTIVITY GOING TO
DISRUPT THE OTHER USES OF THE
RIGHT OF WAY THAT KIND OF
THING- BUT YOUR QUESTION WAS
MORE GENERALLY DIRECTED TOWARDS
THE ENVIRONMENTAL EFFECTS OF
RADIOFREQUENCY EMISSIONS. AND
SO NDER THE TELECOMMUNICATIONS
ACT THE LAST TWENTY SOME ODD
YEARS LOCAL GOVERNMENTS HAVE
NOT BEEN ABLE TO TAKE THAT INTO
ACCOUNT. WHEN DETERMINING
WHETHER TO APPROVE OR DENY AN
APPLICATION FOR AN ANTENNA A
LITTLE LESS THE ANTENNA IS
DEMONSTRATED SHOULD NOT BE IN
COMPLIANCE WITH STANDARDS SET
BY THE FCC SO THIS DOESN'T MEAN
NECESSARILY THAT LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS CAN'T CONSIDER THIS
ISSUE BUT IT'S A SEPARATE ONE
FROM THE PHYSICAL DEPLOYMENT OF
PARTICULAR SITE ESPECIALLY WHEN
WE'RE ONLY GIVEN MAYBE SIXTY
DAYS TO RUBIO APPLICATION WE
DON'T NEED OR NECESSARILY HAVE
THE TIME. TO GO THROUGH A FULL
REVIEW OF ALL THE SCIENTIFIC
EVIDENCE WE ARE LEGALLY
RESTRICTED TO JUST WHETHER THE
APPLICATION WOULD COMPLY WITH
THE FTC'S LIMITS ARE NOT.
CITIES CAN AND DO TAKE ISSUE
WITH THIS AND ONE EXAMPLE WOULD
BE THE RECENT CASE OF THE DC
CIRCUIT ENVIRONMENTAL HEALTH
TRUST USES FCC WHERE THE
PETITIONERS WERE ABLE TO HAVE
THE DC CIRCUIT STRUCK DOWN THE
FCC'S CLOSING OF A NOTICE OF
INQUIRY INTO CHANGES TO THE TO
THE ERROR FEDERAL LIMITS SO IT
IS NOT A CLOSE QUESTION BY ANY
MEANS BUT ON INDIVIDUAL SIDE BY
SIDE SPACES IT IS A MUCH
NARROWER IN KOREA JUST
COMPLIANCE. WITH THE SEC'S.
STANDARDS THANK YOU OUR NEXT
QUESTION IS THERE ANY POTENTIAL
FOR INVESTMENTS IN STREAMLINING
EDUCATION TOWARDS JOBS. THAT
INVOLVE THE DEPLOYMENT
MAINTENANCE AND USING A FIVE G.
TECHNOLOGIES. WELL I'LL I'LL
TAKE THIS ONE JUST TO START OFF
BUT BECAUSE I THINK I MENTIONED
SOMETHING ABOUT IT EARLIER- ONE
OF THE THINGS THAT CAME OUT OF
THE FCC'S MOST RECENT
RULEMAKINGS ON SMALL WIRELESS
FACILITIES. WELL AS THE
OBLITERATION OF THE DISTINCTION
OF MUNICIPAL PROPERTY RIGHTS
VERSUS THE REGULATORY
AUTHORITY. AND THAT DISTINCTION
WAS ONE OF THE BASIS ON WHICH
WE WERE ABLE TO CREATE
PARTNERSHIPS WITH INDUSTRY AT
LOCAL- SO FOR EXAMPLE A. J.
EXPEDITED- LEASING PROCESS USE
OR REDUCE LEASING FEES AND
EXCHANGE FOR IN KIND
CONSIDERATION BY FOR EXAMPLE.
GRANTS TO SMALL BUSINESSES
DEVICE IS A SMALL BUSINESSES
NATURE. BECAUSE ALL OF AT
PROPRIETARY AUTHORITY HAS BEEN
GRANTED WE'VE SEEN A KIND OF.
BOTTOM FALL OUT OF THOSE TYPES
OF ARRANGEMENTS BEING HI THERE
ARE OTHER WAYS OF TRYING TO
PARTNER WITH THE INDUSTRY BUT
THEY'RE JUST BECOMING SMALLER
AND SMALLER FROM THE
PERSPECTIVE GOVERNMENTS SO WE'D
CERTAINLY BE INTERESTED IN
HEARING CLEAN INDUSTRY ABOUT
WHERE THEY THINK THE
OPPORTUNITIES WOULD BE. I GUESS
THAT WAS BROUGHT BACK MY WAY I
DO THINK THAT THERE ARE
OPPORTUNITIES TO PARTNER AND I
THINK THAT- I ONLY CAN SPEAK ON
BEHALF OF T. MOBILE BUT I DO
THINK THAT INDEPENDENT OF
WHETHER OR NOT A JURISDICTION
SPECIFICALLY IT'S ASKING FOR US
TO PARTNER THERE ARE WAYS AND
PROGRAMS THAT HAVE ALREADY BEEN
CREATED THAT ALLOW FOR THAT TO
HAPPEN ANYWAY- FOR INSTANCE- T.
MOBILE HAS A PROGRAM CALLED
PROJECT CAN BILLION RIGHT WHERE
IT DOES- PARTNER WITH A LOCAL.
MUNICIPALITIES AND ALSO SCHOOLS
TO PROVIDE SERVICES TO AT YOU
KNOW AT UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES
IN UNDERPRIVILEGED COMMUNITIES
SO I DO THINK THAT THERE ARE
OPPORTUNITIES IN CREATIVE WAYS
THAT ARE STILL THAT STILL EXIST
RIGHT THAT CAN BE DISCUSSED AND
I THINK THE KEY- I. CALL YOU
TRIPS SO I'M GONNA CLEAN THE
KEY IS TO HAVE THOSE AND MAKE
SURE THAT THE WIRELESS
INDUSTRY- INCLUDED IN SOME OF
THE CONCERNS ALONG THE WAY- AS
I MENTIONED EARLIER ON IN SOME
OF MY COMMENTS I THINK THAT
THAT. IS THE BEST WAY FOR US
TO. GET TO A POINT WHERE ALL OF
THE OPPORTUNITIES THAT MIGHT BE
WITHIN THE COMPANY ARE-
EXPLAINED AND PRODUCED AND SO
THAT WE CAN COME TO
PARTNERSHIPS ANYWAY BECAUSE I
DO THINK THAT SOME COMPANIES
ARE DOING THAT INDEPENDENTLY
ANYWAY FOR THE GREATER GOOD OF
THE COMMUNITY. SO THERE THEY
ARE AVAILABLE THEY MAY NOT JUST
BE- SOMETHING THAT WE MAY BRING
TO THE TABLE AND USUALLY WHEN
BURGEONING APPLICATIONS ARE
ASKING TO BE PLACED ON A- YOU
KNOW WOOSTER STREET WRITER POLL
BUT THEY'RE DEFINITELY THERE
AND I KNOW FOR T. MOBILE WE
HAVE SEPARATE PROGRAMS- I
RECENTLY WENT. OUT ABBACY
INDIGO WE HAD- A LOT OF
PROGRAMS THAT DEALT WITH THE
MILITARY WHICH WAS SOMETHING
THAT WAS OF INTEREST TO. THE
CITIES HERE AND SO THEY WOULD
ASK QUESTIONS ABOUT THAT AND IT
WOULD OPEN UP THE DIALOGUE SO
THAT WE CAN SAY OF. ALL OF THE
THINGS THAT WERE AVAILABLE THAT
COULD BE DISCUSSED A NUMBER ON
THE TABLE- TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
ARE PARTNERING. BECAUSE THE
COMMUNITIES THAT THAT MAY NEVER
MISS A MINUTE VALUE SERVER ALSO
THE COMMUNITIES THAT ARE OUR
CUSTOMERS RIGHT SO WE NEED TO
REALIZE THAT. IT'S A VALUE TO
IT. SO I THINK ALL CARRIERS
WOULD SAY THE SAME THING. THAT
THEY HAVE THOSE- SHIFTING
PROGRAMS IN THE FOR USE MISTER
CHAIRMAN IS RUDY RANSOM VERIZON
IF IT IF IT PLEASES YOU ARE
LOVE TO HEAR MR MADE QUITE
HOWEVER SO A YES I DID YES- I
DIDN'T REALIZE YOU STILL WITH
US THANK YOU GO AHEAD PLEASE
SURE YEAH NOT BEEN WITH A
GREAT- INTO TO THE SO BUT RYZEN
IN THE INDUSTRY STAND READY TO
PARTNER WITH LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
GETTING THIS NETWORK BUILT- IT
DOESN'T JUST REQUIRE A CHANGE
OF LAWS AND LOCAL REFORM IT
REQUIRES A PARTNERSHIP BUT I
CALL SMALL P. PARTNERSHIP. WITH
LOCAL GOVERNMENT AND THE WORK
THAT THE FCC AND THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND MANY CITIES
THROUGHOUT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA HAVE DONE TO-
STREAMLINED THEIR RULES AND
REGULATIONS ARE NOT DONE AT THE
EXPENSE OF PARTNERING WITH
INDUSTRY I THINK AT AND I'LL
I'LLTELL YOU RIGHT NOW THE
RISE IS VERY INTERESTED IN YOUR
PARTNERING WITH INDUSTRY WHAT
WE SEE. THE PROBLEM IS THAT
THERE ARE MANY GOVERNMENTS
INCLUDING MY HOMETOWN OF SAN
FRANCISCO WHICH SAY WE WANT TO
PARTNER WITH YOU BUT WHAT
THEY'RE DOING IS THEY'RE
HOLDING A GUN TO THE HEAD OF
INDUSTRY STANK OR. WE WON'T
COMPLY WITH THE LAW THAT'S NOT
PARTNERSHIP THAT'S COOL SO WHAT
WE NEED IS COMPLIANCE WITH THE
LAW AND THE PARTNERSHIP TO GET
THIS NETWORK BELT AND WE
ABSOLUTELY WE PARTNERED WITH
THE CITY OF SACRAMENTO THE CITY
OF SAN JOSE THE CITY OF LONG
BEACH THE CITY OF SAN DIEGO
CITIES ALL ACROSS CALIFORNIA
AND WE ABSOLUTELY ARE READY TO
CONTINUE TO DO THAT BUT WE NEED
THE OTHER SIDE TO ACT IN GOOD
FAITH AND AGREED. TO FOLLOW THE
LAW. THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND
I'M AFRAID THAT THAT'S ALL THE
TIME WE HOUSE. OF FOR THE
PRESENTATION SO BEFORE WE GO TO
PUBLIC COMMENTS AT THIS TIME I
WANT TO THANK LL THE
PANELISTS. FOR JOINING US AND
ALSO FOR SHARING YOUR EXPERTISE
WITH US AND- WE ARE VERY MUCH
IN FORM AFTER THE HEARING SO I
WANT TO THANK YOU. ARE NOW
LET'S TURN TO PUBLIC COMMENT
AND- FOR THOSE PANELS WHO LIKE
TO STAY ON FEEL FREE TO DO SO.
AND I. BELIEVE WE HAVE ALL FUND
NOBODY HERE IN THE AUDIENCE- IN
PERSON- TO MAKE PUBLIC COMMENTS
SO LET ME GO TO THE PHONE
LINES. IN ASK THE CALL IS TO-
MAKE THEIR COMMENTS AND
REMARKS- AND I'D LIKE TO ASK
THAT YOU LIMIT YOUR COMMENTS TO
ALL ONE MINUTE- APPROXIMATELY
IF POSSIBLE SO WITH THAT. LET
ME GO TO THE PHONE LINES. THANK
YOU IF YOU'D LIKE TO STAY
PUBLIC COMMENT YOU MAY PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO. ONE AND THEN
ZERO FOR ANY PUBLIC COMMENT AND
WE WILL GO TO LIE IN TWENTY ONE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. ONE TWENTY ONE IS THAT
ME AND MY IN COMMITTEE. I YES
YOU ARE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
EXCELLENT YOUR YOUR PHONE.
SYSTEM SOMETIMES HAS SOME
DIFFICULTY AS YOU PROBABLY KNOW
ABOUT SINCE YOU HAD SOME
DIFFICULTY WITH THE VOLUME YES
MY APOLOGIES FOR THAT THAT WE
LOST PART OF THE AUDIO
BEGINNING SO I APOLOGIZE AND-
AND I'LL REPEAT SOME OF THE
COMMENTS ARE. FUNNY THIS IS A
THIS IS ABOUT TECHNOLOGY AND
YET WE ARE DEFINITELY EVEN
LIVING EXAMPLES RIGHT NOW OF
THE LIMITATIONS OF TECHNOLOGY.
SO THAT BEING SAID I WANTED TO
START OFF BY SAYING THAT I
THINK IT IS QUITE TELLING AND
FRANKLY REALLY SUSPECT THAT
MANY OF THE WITNESSES AND
SUPPOSEDLY EXPERTS TODAY-
REPRESENT TELECOMMUNICATIONS
COMPANIES AND THEIR INTERESTS
ADDITION YOU WHAT LEADERS ARE
ALREADY CALIFORNIANS WITH EDT
THE CPUC THEWATER SHORTAGES
AND BACK AND BASICALLY JUST
ABOUT EVERYTHING ELSE THAT YOU
TOUCH AND NOW YOU CERTAINLY
THINK YOU'RE GOING TO SOMEHOW
SUCCESSFULLY GET INTO THE
BUSINESS. OF DISPENSING FIVE G.
FOR CALIFORNIANS AND IN THIS
HEARING WE LISTEN TO YOUR
SUPPOSED EXPERTS FOR OUR- WHILE
YOU'VE BEEN WHAT THE PUBLIC FOR
ONE MINUTE YOU KNOW WHERE
PEOPLE GOING GOVERNMENT WE
DESERVE TO HAVE OUR VOICES
HEARD FRANKLY SIXTY SECONDS FOR
A TOPIC OF THIS MAGNITUDE IS
TOTALLY UNACCEPTABLE YOU SHOULD
HAVE AVERAGE CALIFORNIANS
SPEAKING IN THE HEARING NOT
SIMPLY COMMUNICATION EXPERT A.
K. A. YOUR SPECIAL INTERESTS I
FIND THIS SHAMEFUL AND NOT
BEING SAID I WILL ALSO READ
FROM A SCIENTIFIC AMERICAN
ARTICLE OCTOBER SEVENTEENTH
TWENTY NINETEEN CITING THIS
LARGE BODY OF RESEARCH MORE
THAN TWO HUNDRED AND FORTY
SCIENTISTS WHO HAVE PUBLISHED
PEER REVIEWED RESEARCH ON THE
BIOLOGIC AND HEALTH EFFECTS OF
NON IONIZING ELECTROMAGNETIC
FIELDS EMF. SIGNED THE
INTERNATIONAL EMF FINANCES THE
PEEL WHICH CALLS FOR STRONGER
EXPOSURE LIMIT HE'LL MAKE THE
FOLLOWING NUMEROUS RECENT
SCIENTIFIC PUBLICATIONS HAVE
SHOWN THAT YOU'RE NOT AFFECTS
LIVING ORGANISMS OUT LEVELS
WELL BELOW MOST INTERNATIONAL
AND NATIONAL GUIDELINES THE
FACTS INCLUDE INCREASED CANCER
RISK CELLULAR STRESS INCREASE
IN HARMFUL FREE RADICALS.
GENETIC DAMAGES STRUCTURAL AND
FUNCTIONAL CHANGES OF THE
REPRODUCTIVE SYSTEM LEARNING
AND MEMORY DEFICITS
NEUROLOGICAL DISORDERS AND
NEGATIVE IMPACTS ON GENERAL IN.
THE WELL BEING OF HUMANS DAMAGE
GOES BEYOND THE HUMAN RACE AND
THERE IS GROWING EVIDENCE OF
HARMFUL EFFECTS ON BOTH PLANT
AND ANIMAL LIFE SINCE FIVE G.
THE NEW TECHNOLOGY THERE IS A
NARROW RESEARCH ON HEALTH
EFFECTS SO WE'RE FLYING BLIND
QUOTE A U. S. SENATOR. AND I
COULD GO ON AND ON BUT YOU'VE
ALREADY GIVEN ME MORE TIME I
SUSPECT THERE'S MORE PEOPLE IN
Q. WHO WANTTO SPEAK. AND
PLEASE NEXT TIME WITH YOUR
HEARING LITTLE BETTER FOR THE
OF THE P. BECAUSE AFTER ALL IT
IS A WE THE P. NOT ARE THE
GOVERNOR THANK YOU THANK YOU
FOR YOUR CALL THE NEXT CALLER
PLEASE THANK YOU AND WE WILL GO
TO LINE AT SEVENTEEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. YEAH MY NAME CAPTURE
MUCH BROADCASTER COUNTY
RESIDENT YOU DISCUSS THE
OPPORTUNITY. OF YOUR FIVE G.
BUT LET'S TAKE A CLOSER LOOK AT
THAT THE CHALLENGES. I AM VERY
CONCERNED ABOUT THE BY G. ADAM
HEALTH AND SAFETY CONCERNS
THEIR TECHNOLOGY BEING ROLLED
OUT WITHOUT PRE TESTING PER
SHORT OR LONG TERM HEALTH
EFFECTS. IS OBVIOUS A CONFLICT
OF INTEREST IN THE PALACE WHERE
THE DOCTOR SPEAKING OUT ISN'T
HEALTH CONCERN BUT HE'S PROVEN
HEALTH HAZARD BECAUSE FORTY
THREE G. TWO G. FREQUENCIES UP
ALL SHOWN ARE FOR HARMFUL
BIOLOGICAL ATTACK. IN THE TENS
OF THOUSANDS OF PEER REVIEWED
SCIENTIFIC STUDIES THE LARGEST
ROUTE THAT HE EVER FUNDED IN
THE USA AND P. P. THIRTY
CONCLUDED THAT TWO G. EXPOSURE
ALONE IS ENOUGH TO CAUSE BRAIN
HEART LIVER CANCERS AND OTHER
TUMORS. ANOTHER TIME STUDY OF
EAGLE KALE STANDING STOP ON
EXPOSURES HAVE ALSO MADE
SIMILAR CONCLUSIONS AND TYPE OF
CANCER AND ALL THE SAME ORGANS
AT ALSO EXPOSED TO ONLY TWO G.
RADIATION WHY DO WE KNOW BUDGET
THAT BECAUSE- IT IS THE RELEASE
OF THE ENTIRE MICROWAVE
SPECTRUM WHICH WILL CONTINUE.
TO INCLUDE THE FORGIVENESS ON
IT FORTY THREE G. TWO G. NONE
OF IT'S GOING AWAY BUT THE
ENTIRE. STAFF IS BEING.
AUCTIONED OFF LIKE WITHOUT
OVERSIGHT A REGULAR YOU SEE
THAT THE THING THE RESULT DOOR
BE AND GOT THE PURPOSE OF FIVE
G. ALONG WITH ALL THE NEEDS
BRING ON THE OF THINGS CREATING
A WORLD WHERE ALL THINGS ARE
CHIPPED CAPABLE TO WAY
TRANSMISSION TO ALL LIVING AND
NON LIVING THINGS. ARE COUNTED
FOR CONTROLLED SURVEILLED AND
DATALOG INTO GLOBAL MAIN
MAINFRAME ALL DONE WIRELESSLY
USING ALL THE G. TO COME THAT
SHE'D NEED GOAL OF CALL
SURVEILLANCE DOWNLOAD THE BILL
OF BERMAN THEY YOUR DWELLING
WITHIN THESE WITH THE WRAPPING
MICROWAVE RADIATION
TECHNOLOGIES BEING HIGH
FREQUENCY MILLIMETER WAVE GIVES
OFF THE SAME DOSE OF RADIATION
AND AIRPORT GUARANTEE SAME
MILLIMETER WAVE HAVE BEEN USED
BY THE U. S. ARMY AS CROWD
CONTROL THE BURKE THE WEAPON
CALLED ACTIVE DENIAL SYSTEM THE
COMBINATION OF THE NEW FIVE G.
MICROWAVE TECHNOLOGY ALONG WITH
SMART METERS MIGHT JUST BE.
BECOME AN ALL IN ONE WEAPONS
AND SURVEILLANCE SYSTEM IF I
CAN. ASK YOU DIRECTLY IS NOT
IT'S ALWAYS BETTER IN THE CAN
MARICANN AND LIFE AS WELL THE-
OF BEES HAVE BEEN DEAD AND NINE
EIGHT CHILDREN WITH THEIR
ACCOUNTS YOURSELF PHONE TOWERS
NEXT TO THE WE'RE NEXT TO THE
TOWER TRANSCENDED HUNDREDS OF
PEER REVIEWED STUDIES AROUND
THE WORLD THE LIST LINKED IF
NON IONIZING FORMS
ELECTROMAGNET THE EIGHT MINUTE
RADIATION TO CANCER DNA DAMAGE
INFERTILITY LEARNING AND MEMORY
DEFICITS NEUROLOGICAL DISORDERS
THE NEGATIVE IMPACT ON GENERAL
WELL BEING IN HUMANS FOLLOW THE
SCIENCE THE RISK OUTWEIGH THE
BENEFITS THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NINETY HOUR WORK FOR HIM ON
THE- THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR
YOUR COMMENTS OUR NEXT CALLER
PLEASE THANK YOU WILL GO TO
LINE TWENTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. I'M GOOD MORNING MY NAME
IS MELISSA MCCARTHY I'M IN
SHOCK THE COUNTY- I'D LIKE TO-
SAY THE GENTLEMAN THAT YOU
MENTIONED EARLIER IT WASN'T UP
TO COUNTY LEVEL. TO THE FIVE
FIVE G. FIVE G. DECISIONS AND I
WOULD DISAGREE. I WOULD SAY YES
ABSOLUTELY IS UP TO LOCAL LEVEL
POLITICS NOT ABOUT AND WHERE WE
CAN ONLY BE HEARD- I WANT TO
READ THE CHILDREN'S HEALTH
FOLLOW SUIT FOR MANY YEARS
LARGE GROUPS WITH A DIFFERENT
BALL AROUND THE REAL WORLD
INCLUDING IN ANOTHER HAVE BEEN
WORKING TO INCREASE AWARENESS
OF THE HARMFUL EFFECTS OF
ELECTRO MAGNETIC FIELDS AND
RADIATION AND ARE CONSTANTLY
ASKING THEIR GOVERNMENTS TO
PROTECT THE HEALTH OF OUR
CITIZENS. IN ANOTHER LANGUAGE
AS ANOTHER PARTS OF THE WORLD
THERE PLEASE GO UNANSWERED SO
THAT IS MY FEAR THAT THAT WILL
HAPPEN HERE AS WELL. ON THE
PRETEXT OF- JUST HAVING FASTER
INTERNET AND NOT BEING BEHIND
OTHER COUNTRIES LIKE CHINA. AND
JAPAN ALSO FROM TRACTOR DOT DOT
COM SAN JOAQUIN COUNTY PARENTS
BELIEVE RADIATION FROM A FIVE
G. CELL TOWERS CAUSING CANCER
IN SCHOOL CHILDREN DOCTORS HAVE
DIAGNOSED AT LEAST FOR KIDS
FROM THE COUNTY BELUM ENTRY
CONSISTENT. PARENTS BELIEVE
THAT ONE SPECIFIC CELL TOWER
POSES THE BIGGEST HEALTH
CONCERNS. WE HAD A DOCTOR TELL
US THAT IT'S A 100%
ENVIRONMENTAL THE KIND OF TUMOR
THAT HE HAD SAID MONICA
THOROUGHLY. FROM CVS SACRAMENTO
SO THAT IS MY COMMENT AND I TO
OUT OF ANECDOTE WHEN I INTO A
HOUSE THAT I WAS BRANCHING AT
ONE TIME. I HAD BOUGHT ENOUGH
RADIATION INSTRUMENT TO GAUGE
BECAUSE I LIVED UNDER- TELL
TELLER LINE AND IT'S NOT THE
ACTUAL POWER THAT HOLDS THE
LINE BUT THESE ARE JUST YOUR
REGULAR LINE- OR- YOU KNOW FOR
ENERGY BUT IF THE LINES
THEMSELVES THAT YOU CAN HEAR.
YOU CAN HEAR THE
ELECTROMAGNETIC. FIELDS AND SO
I HAD THE EMF RADIATION METER
AND I WALKED OUT THERE AND IT
WOULD BE VERY HIGH IN THE
HIGHER LEVELS FOR EMF AND RF
RADIATION SO THANKS THAT'S NOT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR SHARING.
YOUR- YOUR TESTIMONY THANK YOU
NEXT CALL A PLACE THANK YOU A
LOT MOVED TO LINE OF EIGHTEEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN YEAH HI MY
NAME STANDS ON THIS AND I WORK
FOR EIGHTEEN FOR TWENTY TWO
YEARS AND HAD STARTED SPICING
CONTROLLED ENVIRONMENT WHILE TO
SILICON VALLEY AND I'VE SEEN.
THE SAME TECHNOLOGY TWENTY
YEARS AGO STILL GOING INTO THE
GROUND IN THE VALLEY YEAH I'LL
ACTUALLY I HAVE NEVER LIVED UP
TO THE SOCIAL CONTRACT OR
COMMITMENTS MADE TO RURAL
COMMUNITIES. THE PROOF OF THAT
IS THE DISMAL FAILURE OF ONLINE
LEARNING MANY GIRL CHILDREN THE
POOR SIGNAL QUALITY OF THOSE
WIFI HOT SPOT IN THE LACK OF
ANY OTHER OPTION. BECAUSE
ACTUALLY CAUSED THE DEATH OF
NEURAL PATHWAYS BECAUSE THEY
WERE UNABLE TO LEARN IN SOME
CASES THEIR CHILDREN THAT I'M
AWARE OF THEY ACTUALLY
COMMITTED SUICIDE FIVE G. IS A
MYTH. LIKE SEEDING THE CLOUDS
ARE THE LOW ORBIT SATELLITES-
BASICALLY THAT WILL TAKE A
GENERATION OR MORE TO DEPLOY.
AND IT WILL HAVE IT WILL BE
ANOTHER GENERATION OF OUR
CHILDREN AND OUR RURAL
COMMUNITIES WILL HAVE TO SUFFER
WHILE THEY WAIT FOR THAT TO
HAPPEN IN THE MEANTIME YOU CAN
DEPLOY FIBER NOW. THE LAST
POINT I'LL MAKE IS THAT THEY
COULD FOR THE AMOUNT OF FIBERS
THAT I'VE SEEN GOING INTO THE
DEPLOYMENT OF FIVE G. WHICH ARE
AS YOU SAID THOUSAND FIBER
CABLES. AND WITH THE WITH THE-
THE GLOBAL. SUPPLY CHAIN.
TWELVE TO EIGHTEEN MONTHS
BEHIND WHICH THE CEO OF A TNT
THANK HE ADMITTED RECENTLY. YOU
CANNOT AFFORD TO PUT ALL THOSE
CHIPS AND CHIPSETS AND CIRCUIT
BOARDS AND FIBER IN TERMINALS
AND EQUIPMENT IN THE GROUND FOR
FIVE G. WELL I WILL COMMUNITIES
WAIT. FOR A COUPLE OF MILES THE
BY DO YOU COULD LIGHT UP A
RURAL COMMUNITY WITH WITH THE
OPTICAL FIBER TO THE NODE OR TO
THE PLAN. NOT MANY FARMWORKERS
HAVE FIVE PEOPLE INTO SELF
DRIVING CARS THAT'S THAT
TOTALLY JUSTICE IN GOTTA STOP
WE HAVE A CHANCE TO TURN IT
AROUND NOW BUT WE HAVE TO FIND
LEGISLATORS AGAIN I. CAN'T HAVE
THE FORTITUDE TO DO SO TO
OPPOSE THE INDUSTRY I'VE SEEN
THE SMALL CELL- FIVE THREE
THREE THREE OR THE- QUIRK MILK
BLANK. TOLD THE COMMITTEES.
WITH NO OPPOSITE IT'S JUST LIKE
WHEN DIRECT BY SEVERAL YEARS
AGO OR YEARS AGO WITH VIA AND
UNDER SUBSEQUENT ATTEMPTS TO DO
SO THANK IS AN ORIGINALLY THE
LEGISLATURE LET LET THAT FLY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
THANK YOU FOR YOUR CALL NEXT
CALL A PLACE THANK YOU AND WE
WILL GO TO LINE OF TWENTY SIX
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD HELLO MY NAME IS TANYA
AND I'M CALLING FROM SAN JOSE.
PLEASE DO NOT PUT ANY MORE FIVE
G. IN CALIFORNIA WE DO NOT WANT
TO BE IRRADIATED BY
ELECTROMAGNETIC FREQUENCIES
THAT ARE HARMFUL TO HELP. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH ALL YEAR OLD I'M
NOT DONE OKAY PLEASE CONTINUE.
PLEASE TURN OFF YOUR CALL OR
NEAR RESIDENTIAL AREAS AT THE
MORAL WE WOULD BE HARMING
PEOPLE EXPENSES TO BE.
IMPLEMENTED HAVE IT BE
IMPLEMENTED FAR AWAY FROM
PEOPLE AND OPPOSE IT ALTOGETHER
WELL BETTER GAS THANK YOUNG
THANK YOU FOR YOUR CALL OUR
NEXT CALLER PLEASE THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR WE HAVE NO FURTHER
COLOR THANK YOU AT THIS TIME
THANK YOU OUR LAST CALL FOR
ANYBODY HERE IN THE ROOM. I
DON'T SEE ANYONE ARE ON THE
PHONE LINES. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH- I WANT TO TAKE THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO THANK ALL OF YOU
FOR JOINING US- INCLUDING- THE
PANELISTS AND THE CALLERS AS
WELL I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
SHARING YOUR EXPERTISE AND-
ONCE AGAIN I WANT TO APOLOGIZE
FOR THE LOSS OF AUDIO- IN THE
BEGINNING OF THE PRECEDING SOUL
WHAT I LIKE TO DO IS TO-
PERHAPS REPEAT WHAT I. BRIEFLY
WHAT I SAID EARLIER WHAT I SAID
WAS THAT THAT CALIFORNIA IS AT
THE FOREFRONT OF BOTH
INNOVATION AND EMERGING
TECHNOLOGIES AND WHAT WE DO
HERE IN CALIFORNIA CAN AT TIMES
HAVE A PROFOUND. IMPACT ON THE
REST OF THE COUNTRY AND HOW IT
ADDRESSES TECHNOLOGY ISSUES AND
I'VE THERE'S ONE THING THAT WE
HAVE LEARNED FROM OUR ROLE. IS
ELSE ONE OF THE BIGGEST TOP
TECH HUBS IN THE WORLD IT IS
THAT INNOVATION BRINGS WITH IT-
THE ABILITY TO TACKLE ISSUES
AND- THEY'RE ALSO CHALLENGES
NOW THE INTENT OF TODAY'S
HEARING IS TO LEARN ABOUT SOME
OF THE OPPORTUNITIES. AND
CHALLENGES OF FIVE G.
TECHNOLOGY BY GAINING A BETTER
UNDERSTANDING OF WHAT IT IS ITS
ECONOMIC POTENTIAL THE EMERGING
TRENDS DRIVEN BY IT AND WHAT
GOES INTO THE BUILDING- IN
IMPLEMENTING THESE NETWORKS AND
LET ME UNDERSCORE THE FACT THAT
THIS HEARING IS. AN
INTRODUCTION INTO FIVE G. AND
MAY BE FOLLOWED UP WITH
ADDITIONAL HEARINGS TO STUDY
THE IMPLICATIONS AND SPECIFIC
ISSUES OF FIVE G. FOR
CALIFORNIA AND AS CHAIR OF THE
SELECT COMMITTEE ON EMERGING
TECHNOLOGIES AND INNOVATION I
HOPE TO CONTINUE TO. HOLD THESE
TYPES OF HEARING IN THE FUTURE
IN ORDER TO DO A DEEPER DIVE
INTO A MORE- RODNEY ONCE THOSE
SITUATIONS- AND SURELY THIS
DISCUSSION AND DEBATE AMONG
VARIOUS STAKEHOLDERS AND I DO
ENCOURAGE ALL PARTICIPANTS. ARE
TO CONTINUE THIS DIALOGUE IN
THE MONTHS AND YEARS TO COME
AND IF YOU HAVE ANY WRITTEN
TESTIMONIES PLEASE FEEL FREE TO
SEND IT OVER TO US I WILL BE
SURE. TO RECEIVE IT AND I
REVIEW THE I'M SO WITH I AGAIN
YOU FOR YOUR PARTICIPATION
INCLUDING THE STAFF HERE IN
THIS ROOM AS WELL AS ALL THE-
STAFF MEMBERS WHO HELPED MAKE
THIS A REALITY SO WITHOUT
DOUBT. THANK YOU FOR. YOUR
ATTENTION AND THAT THIS WILL
CONCLUDE OUR HEARING THANK YOU.